GOOD MORNING AND WELCOME TO THE
JOINT LEGISLATIVE HEARING ON
CALIFORNIA INTERNATIONAL TRADE
AND FOREIGN INVESTMENT AND A
PROFILE ON CHINA. I'M ASSEMBLY
MEMBER QUIRK SILVA AND I SERVE
AS THE CHAIR OF THE JOBS AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AND THE
ECONOMY. PROUD TO DO THAT AND TO
DAY I I'LL THOUGH HE IS HELD UP
FOR THE MOMENT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PHIL TEEING WILL BE COCA MEANING
THIS HEARING WITH US.
HE GOT A LITTLE BIT CAUGHT IN
THE RAIN AND HE IS ALSO THE
CHAIR OF THE ASSEMBLY SELECT
COMMITTEE ON ASIA IN CALIFORNIA
TRADE AND INVESTMENT PROMOTION.
UP BEFORE WE HEAR DO ANY OPENING
REMARKS I'D LIKE TO.
INTRODUCE IN INVITE ANY OF OUR
MEMBERS AND I SEE ONE HERE A AND
INVITE THEM TO INTRODUCE
THEMSELVES TO MAKE ANY COMMENT
SO ASSEMBLY MEMBER DR CHOI.
WELL COME UP GOOD MORNING.
STEVEN CHOI REPRESENTING SIXTY
EIGHT THE DISTRICT ARE LOGICALLY
I IN THE CENTER OF ORANGE
COUNTY.
ALSO FORMER MAYOR OF LE. A CITY
OF IRVINE NO WHERE.
CLOSE TO FORTY PERCENT ARE O.
OR API AND A VERY A STRONG
PRESENCE OF.
.
A IMMIGRANTS HAVE FROM A CHINA
TAIWAN. AND KOREA ETCETERA SO
I'M VERY INTERESTED IN OUR.
A MAKING OF LIFE ONE.
TRADE ACTIVITIES SO NOW OUR
STATE THE AND THEN ASIAN
COUNTRIES AND THE PARTICULAR
NEEDS TODAY AT THE TOP I GET
SUCH CHINA LAST YEAR I HAD THE
VISIT THAT TO US. FIVE DIFFERENT
CITIES ARE IN.
A CHINA SO HAPPY TO BE HERE
TODAY.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND I
ALSO WANT TO INTRODUCE A FEW
OTHERS WITH US TODAY WE HAVE.
WORKING INCREDIBLY HARD ON THIS
COMMITTEE IS OUR.
CHIEF CONSULTANT TO THE SOME
LEASE JOB.
TONY SIMONS AND YOU CAN SEE
SHE'S WORKING WORKING. THAT WE
HAVE JESSICA DUONG WHO IS THE
CONSULTANT TO THE ASSEMBLY
SELECT COMMITTEE ON ASIA AND
CALIFORNIA.
SHE HERE RIGHT NOW.
JESSICA O. THERE'S JESSICA BACK
THERE.
SO SHE IS THE COMMITTEE.
.
AUNT CONSULTANT ON SELECT
COMMITTEE ON ASIA IN CALIFORNIA
TRADE AND INVESTMENT PROMOTION
WE ALSO HAVE NEW.
TO OUR TEAM WE HAVE BENJAMIN
WAR HEIGHT TO IS THE SECRETARY
TO THE ASSEMBLY JOBS COMMITTEE
OVER HERE. AND JULIA KING WHO IS
ASSEMBLY. MEMBER REPUBLICAN
CAUCUS CONSULTANT SO THANK YOU
FOR DOING ALL THE SUPPORT YOU DO
TO MAKE THIS POSSIBLE.
TOOK THE PURPOSE OF TODAY'S
HEARING.
IS AND WHAT WE HAVE BEEN DOING
WHAT'S OUR COMMITTEE IS THAT.
THIS IS THE FIFTH.
IN THE SERIES THAT HAVE BEEN
HELD BY OUR JOBS COMMITTEE I AM
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE ARE
DOING WITH OUR AND FOR MORE
INFORMATION ALL HEARINGS. IS
THAT WE ARE EXAMINING THE
STATE'S ECONOMY INCLUDING ISSUES
SURROUNDING CALIFORNIA
COMPETITIVENESS AND UPWARD
MOBILITY ENTREPRENEURSHIP. AND
THE FUTURE OF THE WORK IN THE
WORK FORCE.
I AM PLEASED THAT NOT ONLY ARE
WE ARE BUT ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING
ARE ABLE TO. DO THIS JOINTLY AYE
AND WE KNOW THAT THE MORE WE
WORK TOGETHER NOT ONLY WITH OUR
COLLEAGUES IN CALIFORNIA BUT ARE
ALSO. ARE PARTNERS ANOTHER
COUNTRY THE MORE WE CAN DO
TOGETHER A CALIFORNIA WE KNOW
THAT CALIFORNIA'S BUSINESS
ACCESS UP WE HAVE ACCESS TO THE
MARKET IN CHINA. WE ALSO HAVE
INCREASING CHINESE FOREIGN
INVESTMENT IN CALIFORNIA
BUSINESS AND INFRASTRUCTURE AND
WE DO ENCOURAGE FOREIGN OWNED
FIRMS TO EXPAND IN ONE OR MORE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES.
SO TODAY'S AGENDA MEMBERS WILL
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO HEAR
FROM THE OFFICE OF THE CONSOLE
GENERAL OF THE PEOPLE'S REPUBLIC
OF CHINA. AS WELL AS THE GO
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF BUSINESS
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT BY
ENOUGH MORE SHORTER FORM GOBIZ.
AFTER THE PRESENTATIONS A PANEL
OF PRIVATE SECTOR BUSINESSES AND
ECONOMIC LEADERS WILL SHARE
INNOVATIVE AND HIGH IMPACT.
INITIATIVES THAT THEIR
ORGANIZATIONS ARE UNDERTAKING TO
STRENGTHEN TRADE RELATIONSHIPS
BETWEEN CHINA AND CALIFORNIA.
FOLLOWING THIS PANEL WILL HAVE A
SCHEDULED PUBLIC COMMENT PERIOD.
AND THE INFORMATION GAINED
THROUGH THIS HEARING WILL BE
USED IN THE DEVELOPMENT AND
CONSIDERATION OF PENDING
LEGISLATION AND DISCUSSIONS WITH
GOBIZ ON THE UPDATE TO THE STATE
TRADE STRATEGY. WHICH IS DOING
TWENTY NINETEEN SO YOU CAN SAY
WE'RE NOT ONLY WANT TO HAVE A
HEARING BUT WE ALSO WANT TO BAIT
BE ABLE TO USE THE INFORMATION
FOR FUTURE PLANS. I WE ALSO IT
IS ALSO OUR HOPE THAT WE WILL
LEARN ABOUT NEW MODELS OF
SUPPORTING TRADE INVESTMENT.
THAT COULD BE USED HERE IN OUR
OWN LOCAL COMMUNITIES.
SO IN EFFORTS UP IN OUR EFFORTS
TO COMMITTEE STAFF HAS PERVADED.
A PROVIDED A TRADE THREE SEEN.
WANT TO HOLD THAT UP.
SO WE ENCOURAGE YOU TO TAKE THIS
I KNOW THAT A LOT OF TIME HAS
BEEN.
SPENT ON THAT A IN THIS
EXAMINES CALIFORNIA TRADE BASED
ECONOMY AND HIGHLIGHTS
CALIFORNIA'S AND CHINESE
DEEPENING DIPLOMATIC AND
COLLABORATIVE RELATIONSHIP.
AND IF YOU ARE A NUMBERS PERSON
THERE ARE LOTS OF DATA IN THERE
AND IT WILL GIVE YOU ALL THE
LATEST INFORMATION.
MEMBERS E. I THINK YOU THERE'S
COPY AND ALL OF OUR MEMBERS TO
US AND AT THIS TIME.
WE ARE GONNA GO AHEAD AND MOVE
TO OUR PANELISTS AYE AS WORLD
WHEN THE CHAIR THE NEXT YEAR
COMES AND UP UP WILL LET HIM
JUMP IN WITH OPENING COMMENTS.
SO WE ARE EXCITED AND HAPPY TO
HAVE WITH US TODAY.
THE DEPUTY COUNSEL GENERAL
RENDON GEN AND.
THAT WE WELCOME YOU AND WE HAVE
AYE I KNOW I HAVE MET YOU MORE
THAN THIS FIRST TIME AS YOU ARE
A VISITOR TO OUR STATE CAPITOL
AND YOU HAVE.
MATT AND AND WORKED CLOSELY
WITH OTHER MEMBERS OF OUR API
CAUCUS US SO WE ARE VERY HONORED
TO HAVE YOU TODAY.
.
AND THAT'S GEN FIVE JUNK YES
OKAY THE DEPUTY CONSUL GENERAL
OF THE PEOPLE'S REPUBLIC OF
CHINA IN SAN FRANCISCO THANK YOU
FOR COMING AND YOU MAY BEGIN.
WELCOME.
THANK YOU THANK YOU EVERYBODY
THANK YOU ON OPRAH CHAIRS AND
THE.
ENEMY ASSEMBLY MEMBER AT TROY
ON THE. AT ALL THE STOPS AND.
.
FRIEND THE FROM GOBIES FROM
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
INTERNATIONAL RELATIONS. CHINA
AS HAVE FUN GONNA GOVERNOR'S ALL
FEES.
OF ECONOMIC COOPERATION AND THE
PROBABLY TO INTO PRICES.
I AND MY COLLEAGUES ARE VERY
HAPPY AN OWNER TO BEING WHITE.
TO PARTICIPATE AS A HEARING.
ON.
MY COUNTRY CHINA THE LARGEST
THAT TRADING PARTNER.
OF SUCH CALIFORNIA.
TODAY. I AYE MY COLLEAGUE GOT UP
THE AYE TO FIVE THIRTY OR SIX
O'CLOCK.
JUMP ON THE CAR.
DRIVE TO.
.
ONE AROUND THE FORTY.
FIVE MINUTES AND IN THE RING.
.
WE ARRIVED.
AHEAD OF TIME HERE BETTER DONE
MY GOOD FRIEND.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FIFTEEN HEY
BECAUSE OF TRAFFIC YEAH I ALWAYS
SAY. TIMING CALIFORNIA DEPENDS
ON
PENS ON THE TRAFFIC YEAH SO IT
WOULD BE OF THE FORTY FIVE
MINUTES OR TWO HOURS.
SO WE COULDN'T. HURT TO THE
THOUGH THE GOOD COME AND TELL
GOOD VERY SO FROM ME. ARE ALL
HASTE THE.
ACHIEVEMENT TO PROMOTE ECONOMIC
AND TRADE IT IN CHINA. BUT I
WOULD TELL HIM LATER.
YOU JUST THE SHOWTIME THE RING
WE ARRIVE THE CAPITAL FROM SAN
FRANCISCO I'M JOKING THAT'S
SHOWS THAT THE INFRASTRUCTURE
ALPHA CALIFORNIA IS STILL
WORKED.
IS VERY GOOD.
BUT WE WANT IT TO WORK BETTER
YEAH YEAH FASTER YEAH WE HOPE
CHINESE COMPANY COULD BE PART OF
IT JUST LIKE A WAVE BICU TO
THAT IN JUST A TEN YEARS.
SIXTY PERCENT OF THE VOTE TUTTO
HIGH SPEED RAIL CONNECTING EVERY
CAPITAL ALL FLOOR TWENTY. AND.
THIRTY FOUR PROVINCES WE CAN
COOPERATE WE CAN ACHIEVE MORE.
SINK YOU AND THIS YEAR.
IT TAKES THE FIRST AMOUNTS
THOUGH FOR CHINESE.
AND LUNAR NEW YEAR OF TALK BOTH
CHINA AND THE U. S. LIKE DOGS.
I BET TWO AND IN CHINA THEIR
MORE DOGS THAN IN THE STATE HAD
THAT ALSO A VERY GOOD TO MARKET
FULFILL DOG FOOD AND. OTHERS
BECAUSE THAT CHINA'S HAS THE
LARGEST.
WOE TO.
MIDDLE CLASS.
AND SO A LOT OF TWO MONTHS
TORIES THEM FUMED.
TRIBAL AND ON THE PRODUCTION.
S. HARASSING SO.
A BIG MARKET.
ALSO.
BEHAPPY THAT TO THE YEAR LAST
YEAR LIVE TWENTY SEVENTEEN BIT
IN IS A GREAT PROGRESS.
I CAN FRIENDLY RELATIONS AND
COOPERATION BETWEEN CHINA AND
THE.
US AND CALIFORNIA WE REMAINS
THE LARGEST.
.
MARKET.
AND THE LARGEST TO TREAT
PARTNER.
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THE LARGEST TO INTERNATIONAL
TOURIST OF SOULS.
AND THE INTERNATIONAL STUDENT
ASSAULTS COUNTRY OF CALIFORNIA.
FOR INSTANCE.
LAST A YEAR.
OF CALIFORNIA AND CHINA'S.
GOODS TREAT.
TOTO. OF ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY
FIVE POINT SIX BILLION US
DOLLARS INCREASE THE TEN POINT
NINE PERCENT OF ICE SHOW THE IN
THE.
A VERY GOOD DEBRIEFING.
I BELIEVE TO BE APPRECIATED
VERY MUCH YOU'LL STOP THE.
DO.
I DID AND DO A GOOD JOB VIA A
LOT OF INFORMATION.
ON THE CAR MY STUFF AND. I READ
A LOT.
AND ALSO.
.
CALIFORNIA'S EXPORT TO CHINA
ALSO INCREASED.
DRAMATICALLY AS ALSO SUPPORT
OUR LOW TALK TO A JOB
OPPORTUNITY.
AND.
AND THE LAST A YEAR.
OVER FIVE MEDIAN THAT CHINESE
ON THE U. S. VISITED AT EACH
OTHER'S COUNTRY. AT ON OVER TO
POLAND TO.
FIVE.
MEDIAN CHINESE VISITED THE US.
OF COURSE IS A LIE BECAUSE
THEY'RE BEAUTIFUL NATIONAL
PRODUCT
HERE ING.
AND CALIFORNIA AND ALSO LIKE ARI
NEXT AND FRANCISCO.
LONG BEACH.
.
THE.
CAN BARELY STAND THE ALSO.
LAKE TAHOE ON MY FAMILY VISIT
DELICTI HOLE.
LOST DE LAS YEAR LAST YEAR
ENJOYED VERY MUCH.
AND ALSO SO MANY BEAUTIFUL
SCENERY HERE ATTRACT A LOT OF
CHINESE TOURIST.
AND TENNIS TOURIST ALSO SPEND A
LOT HERE YING YANG IN CALIFORNIA
AKON ACCORDING TO OUR STATISTICS
AND THE ARTISTS.
AT.
TAURUS THE FROM MAINLAND AT.
I RANKING NUMBER ONE ON THE
VOLUME. OF FOR BUYING US
PRODUCTS SOME OF THEM OMITTING
CHINA. BUT I TOLD THEM ALSO IS
MEETING CHINA EXPORT TO THE US
BUT THE REPORT. BACK TO THE U.
S. UP BY TWO MEN AND CHINA BUT
MANY OF THESE PRODUCTS.
.
MATING CHINA IN FACT TO.
IS THAT.
FROM THE FACTORY INVESTED. BY
US AND OTHER WESTERN COUNTRIES.
SO.
THAT'S WHY THE TRADE DEFICIT
THEY SO BIG.
SO.
Y. REASON THEY THAT TO.
THERE ARE SO MANY INVESTORS OPEN
FACTORIES AND THE MADE PRODUCTS.
SUCH AS IPHONE AND EXPOSED TO
THE U. S..
A FOR THE STUDENTS INTERNATIONAL
STUDENT.
IS ALSO A BIG MARKET.
LAST THE YEAR.
AVERY.
SRI.
OF THE INTERNATIONAL NATIONAL
STUDENT IN THE U. S..
THERE'S A ONE FROM MILAN CHINA.
IF ADDING.
FROM HONG KONG SPECIAL
ADMINISTRATIVE REGION MCCALL AS
A OUR AND TAYLOR REGION METES
ONE CHINA. THAT'S NUMBER OF
UCBCP CARE.
SO.
PRESIDENT AND CHANCELLOR ITSELF
A UNIVERSITY SEEM KIND OF PHONY
AND A U. S..
WHEN THEY VISITED THEIR CAMPERS
WELL WHERE CALM THE BEDS THEM.
BECAUSE. ALL THE INTERNATIONAL
STUDENT A CHINESE DISSIDENT.
PLAY US THREE TIMES.
ALL OF PAY THE INTERNATIONAL
TUITION THREE TIME.
ALL OF THE LOCAL CITIZEN. WILL
PAY.
AND ALSO THEY SPEND ON ALTERNATE
ON OZ THERE.
.
DON'T MEET DMITRI'S AND THE
CARS.
LOST THEIR YEAR A LOOM TENNIS
OF STUDENTS.
ON THEIR FAMILIES TO SPAIN DE.
WERE.
TEN FEET AGAIN.
U. S. DAUGHTER ACCEPTED TUITION
FE SO IT ALSO.
A A JOB CREATION.
EATING.
THE US THAT THEY'RE A TOTAL.
LOSS THE YEAR THREE HUNDRED THAT
FIFTY.
SAU ISN'T
CHINESE MAINLAND THE CITY
WOULDN'T.
STUDY IT IN THE U. S. COMPARES
I WOULD LIKE TO SANK SO. THAT
THE US TEACHERS AND PRINCIPALS
SAYS AND DULL ELECTED OFFICIALS
FULL TAKING CAROL FOR OUR
STUDENTS.
.
IN THE CAR WHILE. I WAS OF
JOKING WITH MY COLLEAGUES THAT
TO. LUKA.
LOOK AT.
SO MANY CHINESE PARENTS.
SEND IS THERE.
.
CHILDREN SOME OF THEIR OWN
CHILDREN CHILD TO. THE US.
SO THAT'S SHOW THEIR CONFIDENCE.
ON THE US EDUCATION SYSTEM AND
THAT THAT'S SHOW THEIR
CONFIDENCE ON CHINA US.
RELATIONS.
A IN CALIFORNIA ARE LOOM.
THERE ARE.
.
FIFTY.
SAU ISN'T CHINESE THE STUDENTS.
STUDY AND HERE.
UNFOLDING INVESTMENT TO. IT IS
ALSO GOOD NEWS.
DIRECTING INVESTMENT FROM CHINA
TO CALIFORNIA HAS REACHED THREE
BILLION US DAUGHTER.
DURING LAST THOUGH.
FIVE YEARS.
FROM TWO THOUSAND TO TWENTY
SEVENTEEN CHINA HAS IN VICE CITY
DID THAT INVESTED IN FOUR
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY ONE
PROJECTING CALIFORNIA.
AT A TOTAL AMOUNT TWELVE TWENTY
NINE.
POINT A SEVEN.
BEYOND US ORDER.
IN SUCH AREA AS.
TRANSPORT ON THE INFRASTRUCTURE
RIOS REAL ESTATE.
HEALTH.
AND BAO TACON AND OTHER
INDUSTRIES TENNIS INVESTORS.
.
BECOME THE NEWCOMER IN RECENT
YEARS.
Y. EXAMPLE I WANT TO.
SHARE.
A TO EXAMPLE ALONG TO SHARE
BASIN. THE COMMITTEE ALL DROP. A
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT.
I BELIEVE ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT TO.
COMMITTEE.
AND.
IN THE GENERAL ASSEMBLY BECAUSE
JOB.
EVERYBODY RIGHT NEEDED TELL YOU
HAVE.
OVER ANY THE JOB AND. THEN YOU.
HAVE A JOB YOU CAN. READ YOUR
FAMILY CHILDREN AND YOU CAN.
ONE ONE ONE PERSON VIEW NOTE
DUE TO EXTREME IMPORT COUNTRY IF
YOU. YOU HAVE A JOB AND.
OF GOING TO THE EMPLOYEE IS THE
HOW MANY JOBS WILL BE CREATED
AMONG THEM BOYS THAT. THE
LARGEST. BANK.
IN CHINA AND ALSO IN THE WORLD
ICBC A INDUSTRIAL ON THE COME
COMMERCIAL BANK OF CHINA.
IT HAS.
SET UP A TENT OVERSEAS OWNS A
VAST THE COAST IN THE PAST FEW
YEARS.
AMONG IS ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
THREE EMPLOYEES
ONLY THREE OF THEM.
WELL ASSIGNED FROM CHINA.
ANOTHER ONE HUNDRED. AND THIRTY.
THEY HIRED LOCALLY
THEY ARE YOU SET US CITIZENS.
THE VARYING LOCAL EMPLOYEES
ACCOUNTABLE NINE THREE EIGHT
PERCENT
OF THE TOTAL STUFF.
THE SECOND EXAMPLE IS OF.
THE INVESTMENT OF FROM. A
PRIVATE DISSECTOR HAPPENED TO.
PRY
I WAIT TO INVESTOR HAPPENED.
FROM SHUN DON'T MY HOMETOWN IT
IS CALLED TO. THE OCEAN Y. TO
GROUP.
THE IN BY STATE THAT ONE POINT
SIX BILLION US DOLLAR.
ON THE SECOND.
AT TALLEST BUILDING AND TING SAN
FRANCISCO.
IT IS UNDER CONSTRUCTION.
IT IS CALLED.
LOTION Y. TO CENTER OCEAN WIDE
CENTER.
I VISITED THE THE A CONSTRUCTION
SITE.
TO MAKE SURE THAT TO THEIR
FOUNDATION MUST THE TOUCH.
THE ROCK.
.
I'M THE ATV WILL CREATE T. TO
ONESELF AND DRAW.
MADE IT. UP ONE SO THEN DROPS.
CONSTRUCTION JOB.
FOR THE STATE
DURING A FIVE YEAR CONSTRUCTION
PERIOD. ON ANOTHER ONE SOLDIER
AND MORE JOBS.
FOR THE BUSINESS OPERATION IT IS
THE UP AND APARTMENT BEAUTY IN
AS WELL AS.
HOTEL.
.
I TOOK THE VASES A US WORKERS
THERE THEY TOLD ME THAT IN THE
COMING FIVE YEARS. IV OR NOT
WORRY ABOUT MY JOB.
.
THEY HIRED IT TO BIGGEST THE
LARGEST DEBT CONSTRUCTION
COMPANY.
ALL OF US IN FRANCISCO.
AND TO BE TO THE BUILDING THE
SECOND TALLEST.
BECAUSE OF THE LARGEST THE
TALLEST OF BEAUTY IN.
HAS A CONTRACT THAT IS THE.
CITY GOVERNMENT OF SOME
FRANCISCO.
NO MOBILITY IN SHOULD BE TALLER
DODD.
THEN THERE'S
OTHERWISE WE COMPUTE MORE
FLOORS.
AND FOR THE REVENUE.
IN THE COMING SERGEI YEARS
ACCORDING TO THEIR CONTRACTOR IS
THE CITY GOVERNMENT AND THE
STATE GOVERNMENT IT WILL TURN
OUT THREE HUNDRED MILLION U. S.
DAUGHTER OF TAX.
TO CALIFORNIA AND THE US.
AND ALSO THIS COMPANY SHOW THEIR
THEIR.
.
SOCIAL RESPONSIBILITY.
SO.
A SUCH ATTACKS A LARGE AMOUNT OF
SUBTEXT WE'LL GO TO THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
NURSING.
NOSE RING.
.
BUT THAT THAT BABY SITTING.
FACILITY.
ON THE.
HOSPITAL SUCH KIND OF FOR
FACILITIES INVEST.
IN SEPARATE CISCO.
A ANOTHER EXAMPLE I WANT TO
SHARE.
WE KNOW THAT THE SAN FRANCISCO
AT TEN I SAID THEY'RE
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE HERE.
I SET TO THE TIMING HAVE.
I'VE.
THE SHOT CONFI Y. MINUTES.
.
IN THE TEN YEARS AGO IT IS THE.
GENERAL AT GENERALLY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PHILIP TING MY GOOD
FRIEND AND OTHER.
OFFICERS SUCH AS THE FORMER
MAYOR ED LEE. AFTER THEIR VISIT
CHINA THE.
THEY FIND THE CHINA MARKET IS SO
BIG AND THE.
PRIVATE SECRETARIES GROWING SO.
IT IS ON GOOD IDEA TO.
ESTABLISH.
TEN I SET. UP SOME FRANCISCO.
WELL OWE PHASE OF CHINA. SEWING
THE PASTA TEN YEARS.
THE DUST THE CELEBRATED THERE.
TEN YEAR ANNIVERSARY LAST THE.
WEEK.
THEY ARE PROUD TO ANNOUNCE THAT
THE IN TEN YEARS THE ATTRACTIVE
FIVE POLAND TO ONE BILLION. US
DOLLAR INVESTMENT OF FROM
MAINLAND CHINA. SO SOME
FRANCISCO.
THE SQUARE THE.
THE LAND OCCUPIED ONLY FIFTY.
SQUARE KILOMETERS
THAT'S MEANS THE ONE KILOMETER
ATTRACTED ONE HUNDRED. MILLION
US THE ORDER.
I INVESTMENT OF FROM CHINA SO.
IT'S I COULDN'T FOR THE CITY.
FOR THE PEOPLE FOR THE JOB.
AND THE FULL THEIR FAMILY.
.
RIGHT NO CHINA IS HOLDING THEIR.
NATIONAL GENERATE AT GENERAL
ASSEMBLY RECALL IS THE PEOPLE'S.
CONGRESS AND SET TO THE NEW PLAN
FOLLOWS A COMING FIVE YEARS.
THE MESHES MESSAGES FROM OUR
CONGRESS OUR GOVERNMENT IS NOT
CHINA WE OPEN WIDER. TO THE
OUTSIDE WORLD.
AWAY WELCOME.
MORE BUSINESS FROM THE REST OF
WHAT WALT.
GRAY.
ALTHOUGH WE HAVE. ALREADY.
AT THE LARGEST A TRADING PARTNER
AWFUL OVER. ONE HUNDRED AND
FORTY.
COUNTRIES IN THE REGION SEEMS OF
A WALLED BUT EVERYONE TO.
DO MORE BUSINESS OPEN OUR DAHLE
WIDER.
THAT'S Y. PRISON THE SEATING
PAN OF CHINA INITIATE THAT TO
CHINA VIEW.
.
HOW OLD IS THE FIRST DAY?
INTERNATIONAL IMPORT EXPORT.
IMPORT EXPORTER IN SHANGHAI. A
THE LUMBER THE FIX TO TENS.
IT IS THE EXPECTED DOCTOR OVER
TWO HUNDRED.
AT TWO THOUSAND EIGHT EXHIBITORS
FROM OVER ONE HUNDRED COUNTRIES
AND REGIONS.
ON THE ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND A PROFESSIONAL BUYERS.
FROM BOTH CHINA AND ABROAD.
WE PARTICIPATE.
THAT IS A GOOD TO OPPORTUNITY WE
HAVE ALREADY SHARED THE BEES
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE OF
THOUGHTFUL DNIA ACOSTA OREGON
NEVADA.
AND WASHINGTON THE FIVE OF THE
STATE THESE CONCERT A TEAR
PROVIDE TO CONSERVE OUR SURVEYS
AND THOUGH THEY ARE VERY MUCH A
AND THAT INTERESTED. WE WANT TO
APPLY MORE CALIFORNIA TERRY.
ORANGE.
AND I WILL CUDDLE AND LIKE VERY
MUCH LIKE AVOCADOS HAVE A COLOR
EVERYDAY MY MY WIFE FROM HAVE.
LIKE A TAN DEL ALSO.
DE FOR A. PORTRAIT EVERYTHING
EVERY SCENE YEAH AND ONE NEVER
SET EYES TO SEE YEAH ONE WE WANT
TO BUY MORE.
.
SO.
WE HOPE.
ON OVER CHAIRS STAND
ASSEMBLYMAN TO BE WE ENCOURAGE
YOU YOU ARE.
BUSINESSMEN IN YOUR DISTRICT TO
PARTICIPATE.
THEY STEVEN TO REVIEW.
LIFT.
MORE BLUE SHARE TO SHARE WITH
YOU.
AND ALSO BECOME PAINS IN
CALIFORNIA AND THE OUR. OTHER
STATES ALSO DOING.
VERY AVAIL THE BUSINESS THAT
SUCH AN ACT THAT SUCH AS.
I PULL.
MICROSOFT.
A BOEING.
CATERPILLAR.
.
AND THE TUSSLE ALSO DOES LOVE
SOON SERVING. THEIR CAR THEIR
AVAIL AND THAT THEY HOPE. AS A
CAT. ESTABLISH.
AFFECT TREES THERE IN THE.
AS EARLY AS POSSIBLE.
.
SO I JUST KNOW I AM MAD TO OUR
OF MY GOOD FRIEND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER EVAN LOW. I WANT TO
MENTION ONE SCENE SET AIN'T.
.
THE. GOOD RELATIONSHIP AND
MUTUALLY BENEFICIAL COOPERATION
BETWEEN CHINA AND DE CALIFORNIA.
BEGINS PENNY YEARS AGO OR ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY AND THE ONE
HUNDRED SIXTY YEARS AGO.
ONES THAT SET FIRST CHINESE
GROUP.
OF.
CHENEY'S REAL WORKERS A HIRED
BY LELAND STANFORD TO BEIRUT.
BEGINNING HERE SACRAMENTO TO
NEVADA THE THE FIRST.
TRANSCONTINENTAL RAILROAD. TO
UNITED THE UNITED STATED
TOGETHER.
WHERE PROUD DOTTED?
THESE CHINESE WORKERS THEY ARE
THE PIONEERS OF THE FRIENDSHIP
AND THE CORPORATION.
ALTHOUGH THEY HAS ONLY LABORS
BUT.
THEY ARE LOYAL.
TO THE CONTRACT.
THEY ARE HARD WORKING.
AND THE.
THERE ARE LOYAL TO THEIR.
CONTRACTORS
SO THEY FINISH HERE.
THE WORK INSTEAD OF A FOR
FOURTEEN YEARS.
PUTTING SEVERAL YEARS BECAUSE OF
THE CONTRACT DAYS.
FOURTEEN YEARS THE BIG FULL OF
A IS YOUR PRESIDENT PRESIDENT
LINCOLN.
FINISH.
ONLY SEVEN YEARS SO THEY ARE THE
PIONEERS SIR.
I'M VERY HAPPY AND APPRECIATE
TO.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER EVAN LOW PHILIP
TING AND THE MANY OTHER ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IS SAID TO PASS.
UNANIMOUS TODAY A RESOLUTION
LAST YEAR TO RECOGNIZE THEIR
CONTRIBUTION.
TO CALIFORNIA TO THE FRIENDSHIP
BETWEEN CHINA AND THE CALIFORNIA
AND ALSO.
ON. A TO THE. BUSINESS
RELATIONSHIP.
WRITTEN.
TELEPHONE AND CHINA RIGHT NO
CHINESE COME HERE NOT HAS THE
LABORS.
HAVE A HUNDRED FIFTY YEARS AGO.
THEY OUGHT TOURIST.
INVESTORS.
STUDENTS.
AND SCORES.
AND DIPLOMATS LIKE ME SO.
WE HAVE A LOT TO DO TOGETHER.
WORKING TOGETHER WE CAN MAKE
THIS. WATER BETTER PLACE TO LIVE
TOUGH ALLIES.
GOVERNOR BROWN VISITED TO CHINA
THEIR SUCCESSFUL VISIT LAST YEAR
AND HE IS THE ONLY GOVERNOR HULL
FROM THE U. S..
AND DATA PRESIDENCY RECEIVED HIM
I TELL OUR.
CURRY TOLD THE PEOPLE WHO SPENT
FORTY FIVE MINUTES TO TO TALK
ABOUT HOW TO ENHANCE.
AND.
CORPORATION ON CLIMATE CHANGE
WE HAVE YOUR COAT PARTNER. A
TRADING INVESTMENT TOURISM STAFF
AND OTHERS.
TO.
CAPTURED SO.
THE CONSULATE TED GENERAL
EATING SAN FRANCISCO. AS WELL AS
OURS. WE HAVE A COLLEAGUES HAVE
FROM LOS ANGELES SO.
REVEAL CONTINUE THIS FOR
SUPPORT
AND THE EFFORT OF GENERAL
ASSEMBLY AND THE CALIFORNIA.
STATE COME AND.
IN PROMOTING TRADE.
.
ON THE OTHER QUICKLY INVESTMENT
TOURISM CORPORATION AND OTHERS
PIZZA CHINA WE WILL ALWAYS BE
YOUR PARTNER.
THE PACIFIC A.
OCEAN. IS NOT THE EXACT LARGE.
ONE HUNDRED FIFTY YEARS AGO IT
TO CUT THAT CHINESE THROWING
WORKERS FIRST THE GROUP.
SIRI.
MONTHS.
BY BOAT.
TORI SAN FRANCISCO FROM.
HOW COME BUT TODAY ONLY ANTI
BORROWERS?
GOOD BUSINESS VIABILITY THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH UP.
MISTER DEPUTY WE WILL YOU STAY A
MOMENT SO WE CAN ASK. A
QUESTION.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHOI DO YOU HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU WANTED TO
PRESENT.
THANK YOU THAT TOM FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION.
MAYBE.
I'M IDEA.
YES.
LAST YEAR NOVEMBER.
OCTOBER END OF OCTOBER THROUGH
UP BEGINNING OF A NOVEMBER I HAD
THE PLEASURE OF.
OF VISITING CHINA FIVE DIFFERENT
CITIES OF FROM A STARTING FROM.
SHANGHAI.
FOOD JOE.
POPE CHIU.
SOME OF THE CITY AND ENDED UP.
NAY AND BEIJING.
OUT WITH THEM ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
OF TEN COOLEY.
ALONG WITH THE.
CHINESE BUSINESS.
.
I'M.
COMMUNITY MEMBERS.
THAT WAS.
.
OUR COLLABORATION.
AND THEN ABSOLUTE DUB.
ORGANIZED BY.
FORMER.
SENATOR BOB HUFF.
AND THE MAIN MAIN HUFF. WAS OF
FROM.
A CHINA.
IT WAS SO VERY EDUCATIONAL FOR
ME.
A AND THEN ALSO.
NOW BUILDING THE RELATIONSHIP.
WITH YEAH.
NOW CHINESE GOVERNMENT DOT. AND
THE OR SO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMUNITY CHAMBER COMERS.
.
I AM JUST TO THAT THE VISIT WAS
SO ORGANIZED.
A ANNUALLY.
BUT THE I FELT THAT WAS A LITTLE
BIT TOUR LIMITED.
I WISH THAT THERE WERE.
AT LEAST OR MAYBE.
TEN WHAT DOZEN DIFFERENT NOT.
ASSEMBLY WAS SENATE MEMBERS.
BUT THE.
AND.
TWO MEMBERS TO MYSELF Y. AND.
ASSEMBLYMAN COOLEY WERE.
I AM REPRESENTING OUR STATE THAT
LEGISLATURE.
ALONG WITH THERE'RE CONTINUOUS
EFFORT TO IF YOU CAN
WORK WITH THEM HOW.
TO INCLUDE WHAT INCREASE THE
MEMBERS OF VISITING BECAUSE THAT
THE US OUT A LOT OF WORK THAT
THEY PUT IN TO ORGANIZE.
NEARLY TEN DAYS
SO ARE. A CANVAS AND ONE IDEA
YOU OFFICE CAN. REACH OUT TO
THEM. AND.
AND. I UNDERSTAND UP A LOT OF
WORK.
COULD THE SPONSORSHIP OF TEAM
FROM.
AMERICA BASED A CHINESE SELF
ORGANIZATION IS SOME.
AND THAT THAT MONEY WAS SET ON A
DAY TO THE.
A NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION SO WE
CAN GET BY.
THE. AMERICAN FPC UP REGULATIONS
SO YES SO WE WE HAVE TO MEET UP
WITH THE.
UP PEOPLE'S CONGRESS OUT OF.
SHANGHAI AND BEIJING.
AND.
THAT.
GAVE US OUR.
A B.. EXCUSE ARE.
TO.
AND THAT WAS A BASIS. TO MEET
WITH A COVER MY NOT. OF.
PEOPLE AS WELL AS SO.
.
THE COUPLE MONTH AND THE
BUSINESS IS SO.
SO WHAT I THINK THAT WAS A VERY
WELL ORGANIZED A TRIP.
SO IF YOU CAN.
A I DON'T KNOW IF YOU ARE
FAMILIAR WITH THAT COOL. AND
OTHER SENATOR A PAPA ALPHA. AND
ONLY WISHING CASE THAT THAT THAT
KIND OF WORK EFFORT WILL
CONTINUE. AND.
UP EXPAND THE SCOPE TO INCLUDE
MORE. A MEMBERS TO VENT BENEFIT
FROM THE.
THANK YOU ADOPTED CHILD FIRST
THE.
VERY GOOD IDEAS THAN THE
PREVIOUS SUPPOSED TO AND ALSO WE
WANT TO CONGRATULATE TELLING
YOUR SUCCESSFUL A IT. AND THE
WAY I HAVE PAID TO WORK PLEASE
ABOVE HOOF AND SENATOR BOB HOPE
PHASE ALSO A GOOD FRIEND AND
MAYBE HOA.
FRIEND OF CHENEY TIME ON CHINESE
CONSULATE.
.
MAY AS YOU MENTIONED THERE ARE
MORE ASSEMBLYMEMBER ONE TO VISIT
CHINA AND THE CHINA. AND ALSO
ONE TO WEAR COM.
MORE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FROM THE
SIX LARGEST THE WORLD ECONOMY.
TO ACROSS THE PACIFIC TO VISIT
CHINA YOU HAVE A SISTER STATES
OF. JOHNSON PROVINCE.
AND THE FRIENDLY ANTS.
THE STATE THE RELATIONS OF A
STRONG. EVADES THE.
CITRON PROBLEMS
AND THOSE OF SO MANY FRIENDS IN
CHINA.
REVIEW EXTENDER.
YOUR IDEA BACK TO TO TO YOUR
COLLEAGUES ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND
THESE TWO SISTER PROVINCES AND
THAT. THE CHINESE CONSULATE
THOUGH WE'LL WORK THE. RELEVANT
TO NONPROFIT AGENCIES.
TWO. BASES COMMITTEES
CIVILIZATION A COMMITTEE OF JOB
DONE THE ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
AND SUBCOMMITTEE OF.
A SELECT COMMITTEE OF HAITIAN
AND CHINA.
TELEPHONE AND INVESTMENT TREAT
A PROMOTION COMMITTEE.
TO TO.
ORGANIZE TRIAL BEST TO DO ALL
NIGHT.
I NEARLY AND THE VISIT BY
GENERALLY ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
TO VISIT CHINA.
TO PROMOTE TRADE AND INVESTMENT
THINK OF NO PROBLEM Q. YEAH IT
COULD BE A SEPARATE ENTITY IN
OUR NSA IF THE COLLABORATION IS
HARD TO FOR WHATEVER YOU KNOW
WE.
SET UP BECAUSE THAT THEY HAD
THAT THEIR OWN TRADITIONS SO.
IT COULD BE IT US A SEPARATE
ENTITY WHO CAN ORGANIZE AND.
PROVIDE THE.
A DIFFERENT OPPORTUNITY SO FOR
MORE MEMBERS YEAH YOU A FULL
EDUCATION THE EXCHANGES ALSO
THEY HAVE ALREADY.
EDUCATION COUNSELOR HERE YEAH
NONE TO CONFUCIUS THE INSTITUTE
TO HEAR. THERE ARE LAWS TING.
BEING.
.
THE UNIVERSITY TELEPHONE AND
THAT THE U. S..
WE CAN ALSO DISCUSS THE WHOLE TO
PROMOTE TO SUCH A KIND OF
COOPERATION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND WE ALSO NOTE THAT
OUR VICE CHAIR OF THE. JOBS
COMMITTEE WHO IS NOT HERE RIGHT
NOW BUT ASSEMBLY MEMBER TRAVIS
ALLEN ALSO TRAVELED LAST YEAR ON
BEHALF OF THE JOBS COMMITTEE
OUGHT TO CHINA UP REGARDING THE
IMPERIAL VALLEY INVESTMENT. AND
I KNOW THAT HE REALLY
APPRECIATED THAT SHIP AND AS WE
SAY HERE THE MORE THE MERRIER
HER HOME WHERE THAT GOES TO.
THAT MORE WE LEARN ABOUT I DO
WANT TO WELCOME AYE TWO OF OUR
MEMBERS FROM OUR COMMITTEE WE
HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER KANSEN CHU
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER MARC BERMAN.
HERE AND WE'RE FINISHING UP THE
FIRST PANEL AND SO THEN WE'LL
MOVE ON TO THE SECOND PANEL ON
GONNA ASK A QUESTION IN THE WAY
IF YOU HAVE ANY OPENING REMARKS.
I DID IT I HAVE A QUESTION FIRST
OF ALL IT'S.
THE DATA JUST REALLY TELLS THE
STORY WHICH IS YOU ARE NOT ONLY.
pCALIFORNIA GOES BUT WE KNOW
THAT
YOU ARE YOU.
MAKING HUGE INVESTMENTS IN OUR
COUNTRY AND LIKE FLIES AND IT'S
VERY IMPRESSIVE TO SEE HOW MUCH
INVESTMENT UP BUT AS A FORMER
EDUCATOR. OR REALLY CURRENT YOU
WHEN YOU ARE AN EDUCATOR YOU'RE
ALWAYS AN EDUCATOR.
AYE FIFTY THOUSAND STUDENTS
COMING TO.
NOT ONLY CALIFORNIA BUT ACROSS
THE UNITED STATES AND YOU
MENTIONED YOU HAVE HIGH
CONFIDENCE IN. AND SENDING AND
YOUR PARENTS SENDING THE
STUDENTS TO WHETHER BE
CALIFORNIA OTHER OR OTHER AREAS.
I WANNA ASK WHY THAT IS BECAUSE
SOMETIMES WE HEAR SUCH.
ALARMING NEWS ABOUT OUR PUBLIC
EDUCATION AND AND.
IT'S SOME PEOPLE EVEN.
SAY IT'S FAILED AND I KNOW THAT.
THIS SYSTEMS ARE VERY DIFFERENT
KIND AYE A HEARD THAT.
SOMETIMES PEOPLE VISIT IN THEY
THINK WHAT OF THOSE TEACHERS
DOING THE KIDS OR READING ON THE
CARPET OR OR THEIR.
YOU KNOW PAIN TEAM THEN VIETTO
DOING YOGA WHAT KIND OF SCHOOL
IS THIS SO CAN YOU EXPLAIN WHY
YOU HAVE SUCH CONFIDENCE IN OUR
SCHOOLS.
AND THE PARENTS ESPECIALLY.
.
IS A TOUGH QUESTION BUT THE AYE
VISITS SO MANY COMPARISON I FIND
THE DIED TO.
THE MAJORITY.
UNIVERSITY COMPARES IN
CALIFORNIA AND IN THE STATE.
LOVE VERY GOOD.
I EXCHANGE IDEA RESOLVE
APPLICATION.
CONSIDER JUST NOW ON THE WAY.
AND COMPARE. THE UNWANTED AND
THE SEVEN ONE TAKE OF THAT CHINA
AS THE UNIVERSITY ON THE U. S.
UNIVERSITY.
WE HAD WE BELIEVE THAT YOU
REALLY HAVE YOUR ADVANTAGE.
VERY LET LIBERAL ATMOSPHERE AND
THE TEACHERS THE.
A VERY KIND TERRI OF STUDENTS.
AND THE U. MANY UNIVERSE THAT I
LIKE UC BERKELEY AND.
.
A STANFORD AND STATE UNIVERSITY.
OF SAN FRANCISCO I BASIC THAT.
LOS THE BEAK.
VERY CLEAN. AT TO CHINESE
PARENTS SEND THEIR STUDENT ID TO
THE TRUCE THEY TRY.
TO APPLY THE BEST A UNIVERSITY.
YEAH I REALLY COME SO YOU'RE
TELLING ME THEY LEARN AND SOME
OF OUR HIGHER EDUCATIONS YEAH.
YEAH A LITTLE BECAUSE IT DOCTOR
CHOI THEY LEARN HERE IN
CALIFORNIA NOW I JUST NEED A
LITTLE BIT.
IT BECAUSE SO OFTEN WE HEAR SO
NEGATIVE THINGS ABOUT US AYE
NOTIFICATION SO WHEN WE HEAR
SOMETHING POSITIVE I WANT TO SAY
IT VERY LOUD. HA HA HA.
SO I ASSUME FOR THE.
COME VARIATION ON THE OZ.
PROBLEMS THAT IT'S HAPPENED. IN.
TO SOME.
TEMPERS TO SOME SCHOOL THE
CHINESE PARENTS ALSO MARIO ABOUT
YEAH SO SO MANY NEWS ABOUT THAT
HAD BEEN TO THE PRISON DATE
TREES. AND STILL LOW AND WE RUN
IT RELY ON YOU THE.
PEOPLE'S REPRESENTATIVES TO
PASS THE RELEVANT TO ROLL AT A
TO MAKE THE COMPARISON A SAFER.
NOTABLE ONLY FOR.
ISSUED IN THE CALIFORNIA BUT
ALSO FOR THE FOREIGN STUDENT
INCLUDING FROM CHINA THANK YOU.
S. THANK YOU. ALRIGHT WHAT WE
ARE FINISHING UP OUR FIRST PANEL
AND WE ARE BEEN HONORED TO HAVE
ON THE DEPUTY HERE AND DO YOU
HAVE ANY I'M WOULD LIKE TO
WELCOME OUR.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PHIL TEEING AS
A SPECIAL SELECT COMMITTEE CHAIR
ON ON ASIA YEAH IF YOU HAVE ANY
WELCOMING OR OPENING MARKS AND
THEN WE'LL GO TO OUR NEXT TO
MEMBERS AND THEN START OUR
SECOND PANEL. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER I APOLOGIZE ABOUT BEING
LATE THE.
SARITHA AND MIST.
DIFFICULTY GENERAL'S. TALK BUT
I CAN IMAGINE.
SOME THE VERY PORTANT ITEMS
THAT HE.
HIGHLIGHTED I KNOW THAT.
FOR SUBS Y. THANK YOU FOR
HOLDING THIS HEARING ON THIS
VERY IMPORTANT SUBJECT. ON AT A
TIME WHEN THE UNITED STATES IN
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ARE
UNFORTUNATELY I THINK MOVING IN
A LESS POSITIVE DIRECTION.
I THINK IT IS IMPORTANT FOR
CALIFORNIA TO REITERATE.
THAT THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
CALIFORNIA AND CHINA IS
EXTRAORDINARILY IMPORTANT.
BOTH CULTURALLY AND
ECONOMICALLY ON.
AND GIVEN THE LARGE NUMBER OF.
CHINESE AMERICANS WHO RESIDE IN
CALIFORNIA IN THAT RELATIONSHIP
AYE IS EXTRAORDINARILY IMPORTANT
HAS ACTUALLY GONE ON FOR WELL
OVER A HUNDRED YEARS.
SO I THINK IT IS SO GOOD FOR US
TO REITERATE SOME OF THE.
TRADE AND INVESTMENT ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY YOU CAN HEAR FROM.
DARLENE CHIU IN IN CHINA
SEPARATIST ORGANIZATION I HELPED
FOUND IN VERY VERY PROUD OF ALL
THE.
ACCOMPLISHMENTS IT'S DONE.
BY FOSTERING TRADE AND. TRADING
LIKE ECONOMIC. RELATIONSHIPS
WITH CHINA AND I THINK IT SERVES
AS A MODEL FOR OTHER CITIES AND
OTHER REGIONS TO. TO REALLY.
LOOK AT.
GOING INTO THIS NEXT CENTURY I
THINK THIS RELATIONSHIP WILL
BECOME EVER MORE IMPORTANT.
ON AS CHINA HAS COMPANIES THAT
ARM MOVING ABROAD EXPANDING
ABROAD.
WE OBVIOUSLY WANT TO CONTINUE
TO HAVE THAT STRONG TRADE
RELATIONSHIP WE ALSO WANT.
CHINESE COMPANIES TO LOOK AT
CALIFORNIA TO OPEN UP OFFICES TO
CREATE JOBS I THINK PRESENTS A
VERY GOOD OPPORTUNITY BOND.
BETWEEN THE CHINESE COMPASS AS
WELL AS OTHER MULTI
MULTINATIONAL COMPANIES
SO AGAIN VERY MUCH APPRECIATE I
YOUR COMMENTS EXCITED TO HEAR
ABOUT ALL THE PROGRESS THAT HAS
BEEN MADE BUT WE KNOW. WE STILL
HAVE QUITE A BIT OF WORK TO DO
THAT THANK YOU.
I THINK YOU SO MUCH AND.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHU. WAS SENT
FIGURE VERY MUCH.
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER SHARON
QUIRK SILVA FOR HOSTING THIS.
A VERY REPORT AND A HEARING I
ALSO APOLOGIZE.
BEING LATE I HELPED THE PRESS
CONFERENCE REGARDING TO MY
DELIGHT SAVING TIME BILL AYE
YES.
HEALTH.
BUT.
O. ALSO ONE THING DO YOU A
DEPUTY CONSUL GENERAL RENFRO.
COMING OVER A TODAY ARE AND
LAST NOVEMBER. I A LADDER
DELEGATION OF THE THE
CHAIRPERSON ALL I MEAN IS
DEPARTMENT HEAD. OF THE ITSELF
JOSE STATE UNIVERSITY AVIATION
DEPARTMENT.
THE THE DEPARTMENT HEAD AS WELL
AS THE VICE.
PRINT A PRINCIPAL OR VICE THE
BROUGH AYE I CAN REMEMBER HIS
TITLE BUT IS IT MUST BE A.
THE THE.
PRESIDENT VICE PRESIDENT UP SAM
LOOKING A COLLEGE TO VISIT.
CHINA
AND TO.
GOOD GOOD DID PURPOSE HEALTH
FACT TRIP IS TO SIGN A MO YOU
BETWEEN CELLS ISSUE UNIVERSITY.
AND THE.
AND YOUNG INSITU ALL TECHNOLOGY.
AND I ALSO POINT OUT THAT SINGS
TO CHINA HAS OPENED UP THE THAT
THE AIR SPACE FOR. THREE
THOUSAND FEET.
THAT CREATES A LOT OF
OPPORTUNITY FOR.
AVIATION AND INDUSTRY.
THERE SO.
I'VE SEEN SO MANY HANG GLIDERS
AND PEOPLE DOING THIS THE SKY
DIVING THEY.
THOSE ONE OR TWO.
PERSON.
AIRCRAFT AND AND GO OF HOT AIR
BALLOON TALK WELL DOES HE REALLY
AS A LOT OF. OPPORTUNITY FOR OUR
OTHER COMPANIES IN CALIFORNIA TO
TO A CRACK INTO THAT.
MARKET AND ALSO.
ALSO NOTICED THAT THE.
VERY GOOD LOCAL GOVERNMENT IS
VERY VERY COME THEY THAT.
WE NEED FOR THIS OF
ENVIRONMENTAL A YOU SHOULD.
AND A GOOD TRYING TO OF CLEAN UP
DAY DICK AYERS AND THE WATER AND
AND MANY OF TO EASE THE CITIES
SO.
AT AS THE CHAIR OF THE ART INTO
TEAM OF SUPPORT.
A TOURIST IN THE IMMEDIATE TACK
THE MEDIA ATTACK.
I ALSO SEE A LOT OF OPPORTUNITY
AND REGARDING TO THE CULTURAL
EXCHANGE.
AND AND ENTERTAINMENT AND
INDUSTRY AND THE POOR SON. I'M
WORKING ON ESTABLISH SOME
SISTER.
OF STATE RELATIONSHIP MOVE WAS
CHINA AND I'M ONE OF THE.
DID THE PROBLEMS THAT WORD BUT
IN PAULK IS WORD AND A DOG.
DEPUTY. CONSUL GENERAL IS FROM
IN THOSE SAN DON'T PROBLEMS WE
FIND OUT THAT.
WOULD WE WE HAVE OUR
STRENGTHS AND WEAKNESSES
IN THE ARE OF PARK.
MANAGEMENT OR OR OR OR A HARD
CA THAT DATE WE HAVE WE ARE VERY
GOOD HERE.
AND CATEGORIZE ALL THOSE.
A.
AB CORPSES.
BUT IN CHINA DO A VERY GOOD OF.
FACE IMPACTED HISTORY AND HAVE
WHO WRITES THE DUE TO CULTURAL.
.
AND AND THE HISTORY OF ALL OF
EVERYONE UP THERE PARKS.
SO THERE SEEMS NO I THINK WE CAN
LEARN FONG THE CHARTER. AND DUMB
I'M DEFINITELY VERY COMMITTED TO
AND IMPROVE BILATERAL.
OPPORTUNITY TO CREATE A DOVE
WING WHEN SITUATION.
PUBLIC PEOPLE OF THE REPUBLIC OF
CHINA AND CALIFORNIA SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR WILL COME.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHU
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN OF
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
FOR ORGANIZING TODAY'S HEARING
AND AND THANKS TO THE DEPUTY
CONSUL GENERAL FOR COMING TO TO
SPEAK WITH US. FOLLOWING UP ON
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHOOSE COMMENTS
ABOUT CAST SISTER STATE
RELATIONS.
AREN'T EARNED SISTER STATES LOS
NATION RELATIONS.
THE FIRST THING THAT I DID
AFTER GETTING ELECTED TO THE
PALO ALTO CITY COUNCIL WAS TAKE
A TRIP TO TO CHINA.
TO SHANGHAI AND HONG KONG'S DO.
AND.
THE CITY OF PALO ALTO ENTERED
INTO A SMART CITY PARTNERSHIP.
NO WITH THE YOUNG WHO DISTRICT
OF SHANGHAI.
THAT'S NOW BECOME A SISTER CITY.
RELATIONSHIP AND.
THE YEAR AFTER WE WENT WE WENT
OUT WE VISITED FOOD ON
UNIVERSITY WE VISITED SOME TECH
TECH INCUBATORS.
WAS FANTASTIC A REALLY GREAT
OPPORTUNITY AND SEEING ALL THOSE
DIFFERENT CULTURAL.
AND KIND OF BUSINESS AND WE ARE
COLLABORATIONS THAT.
CURRENTLY EXISTS IN THE
POTENTIAL FOR A LOT MORE AND THE
FOLLOWING YEAR ABOUT HALF DOZEN
POLL TO HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS
ABOUT WENT OUT AND SPENT. A
COUPLE WEEKS I DURING THEIR
SUMMER BREAK IN SHANGHAI AND HAD
A FANTASTIC.
OPPORTUNITY SO.
THERE'S A LOT OF.
IN OVERLAPPING OPPORTUNITIES
FOR COLLABORATION OF BOTH
CULTURALLY AND IN TERMS OF THE
TECHNOLOGY AND INNOVATION
ECONOMY THAT I REPRESENT.
AND SILICON VALLEY AND AND SO
LOOKING FORWARD TO EXPLORING A
LOT MORE THOSE OPPORTUNITIES.
THANKS.
THANK YOU UP I ENGINEERS ARE
JUST HAVE TO ADD THE SHELLED OUT
FOR.
DID THIS A CALIFORNIA THE FOLKS
HERE HAVE BEEN DOING A VERY VERY
GOOD JOB TO PROMOTE A IT THAT
THE TOURISM BETWEEN CALIFORNIA
AND. AND CHINA AND I WAS SO
CHAIR OF OF DISCOMFORT HE AND I
ALSO WANT TO HAVE A SHOT YOU'RE
SHOT OUT TO DO GOLD THIS. IN THE
AM I HAVE A MET WITH THEM AND WE
HAVE AND STARTED SOME WORK INTO
PROMOTED BILATERAL RELATIONSHIP
SO. FRANCO GOLDMAN ES VERY
TIMELY BECAUSE THEY'RE GONNA BE
COMING OUT ON THE HAVES BUT ONE
LAST QUESTION WHAT YOU SAID MANY
MANY TOURISTS COME TO CALIFORNIA
AND THEY HAVE. THEY LOVE.
CALIFORNIA WHAT'S THEIR
FAVORITE PLACE
IN CALIFORNIA HOCKEY I DIVERT IT
ONE DAY.
EMAIL LARA HA HA HA HA.
OKAY WHAT'S YOUR FAVORITE. WIFE
IN THE NATIONAL PARKS THAT THE
STATE PROMISED HIM HOW THESE
YEAH YOSEMITE.
LOOK TOP HOLE IF SO MANY IN
BEAUTIFUL PLACES AND ALSO SAN
FRANCISCO OFF BECAUSE.
AND IF YOU CAN AND THE BEACHES
THE COASTAL CAN HEAR COULD YOU
ALONG BEACH YEAH AREA ALSO THE
FUMING DOWNSTREAM AND OLIVER
CHAIRMAN WE HAVE AT ONE POINT.
TO POINT ONE THEY THE FUMING
THAT'S TRUE.
AIRY HOLLYWOOD HOLLYWOOD HOW
THEY WILL.
CHINA.
RIGHT NOW I HAVE GROWN TO BE THE
SECOND LARGEST IT.
FEW MARKETS AT THE AUDIENCE.
THE VOLUME STEP AT IS BOOMING
SO.
ONE DAVY ME SUPPOSITORY US
BECAUSE WE HAVE ONE POINT THREE
BILLION PEOPLE HALF OF THE.
FUME.
A BIG FILM STATES A FROM HOLY
VOTE AND WE ARE PROUD DATO WE
ALSO.
A PARTY AND A FULL CONTRIBUTION
TO THE JOB TO UNITY. FALL
HOLLYWOOD STARS AND DIRECTORS.
EVERYBODY WANTS TO BE A STAR A
HA HA HA HA HA THANK YOU AGAIN.
IT'S BEEN AN HONOR TO HAVE YOU.
HAVE IS ALSO I'M I WANT TO SAY A
FEW WORDS TO TO MY GOOD FRIEND.
AT PHILIP.
YEAH I I MENTIONED DOT TO.
TEN EYES HAVE YOU INITIATED
WITH ME THERE HAD TO BE AND THE
OTHERS ON THE.
CONTRIBUTOR LAW TO TO THAT JOB
CREATION TO THE CITY AND
ATTRACTED THE FIVE POINTED
BADIA.
INVESTMENT FROM CHINA A
SEVERITY OF WE WE THINK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ALRIGHT WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD AND
BRING UP DIRECTOR.
AB DO THIS AND IF YOU CAN BE UP
YOUR TEAM.
THOSE WITH.
THE. UNEXPLORED GONNA BE HEARING
FROM THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
BUSINESS GOBIZ.
PART OF THE GOBIZ MISSION IS TO
SERVE AS THE STATE'S LEAD ON
TRADE PROMOTION AND FOREIGN
INVESTMENT ACTIVITIES. IN
UNDERTAKING THIS MISSION GOBIZ
DEVELOPS THE STATE'S TRADE
STRATEGY IN OVERSEAS PROGRAMS
AND SOME SERVICES THAT ARE
DESIGNED TO ENCOURAGE FOREIGN
INVESTMENT AND JUSTICE
CALIFORNIA BUSINESSES AND
ACCESSING FOREIGN MARKETS. AMONG
ALL OTHER COUNTRIES CHINA HAS
HELD ONE OF THE PRIORITY
POSITIONS IN THE STATE'S FOREIGN
RELATIONS AND WILL GO AHEAD AND
HAVE YOU BEGIN. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND.
MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE SHOUT OUT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHU I REALLY. REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT WE'VE DONE A LOT
OF WORK TOGETHER NOT ONLY WITH
THIS A CALIFORNIA BUT ALSO WOULD
GO TO HIS.
AND BERMAN.
SO THANK YOU AGAIN FOR INVITING
US HERE TODAY TO REALLY SHARE
WITH YOU THE WORK THAT WE'VE
BEEN DOING. AYE TO ADVANCE
CALIFORNIA'S TRADE AND
INVESTMENT PARTNERSHIP WITH
CHINA. UP BEFORE I GET STARTED I
DO WANT INTRODUCED ON MY
COLLEAGUES HERE.
SITTING WITH ME IN THIS IS ALL
WE WHO SERVES AS OUR DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR INTERNATIONAL
AFFAIRS AND BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT
AND RHODA OUR PARTNER DOWN IN
LOS ANGELES AT THE AT LOS
ANGELES CONSUL GENERALS OFFICE.
SO COMMERCIAL A TO SHAME.
SO FIRST I'D LIKE TO SHARE SOME
OVER ARCHING BACKGROUND
INFORMATION ON OUR BILATERAL
TRADE AND INVESTMENT
RELATIONSHIP WITH CHINA.
AS THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR GENERAL
MENTIONED YOU KNOW IT'S ONE OF
OUR MAJOR ATTORNEY INTERNATIONAL
TRADING PARTNERS.
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN CALIFORNIA
EXPORTS TO CHINA TOTALED SIXTEEN
POINT FOUR BILLION SO IT'S ONE
OF THE HIGHEST TOTALS IN THE
NATION WITH COMPUTERS AND
ELECTRONIC PRODUCTS ACCOUNTING
FOR ROUGHLY A QUARTER OF ALL
EXPORTS.
ALSO IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN INBOUND
INVESTMENT FROM CHINA ALONE
TOTALED FOUR POINT SEVEN
BILLION.
A LEADING INDUSTRY SECTORS FOR
INWARD INVESTMENT FROM CHINA OR
INFORMATION AND COMMUNICATION
TECHNOLOGIES REAL ESTATE
HOSPITALITY AND HEALTH AND
BIOTECHNOLOGY.
I THE INTERNATIONAL T. MAKEOVERS
SUPPORTS BILATERAL INTERNATIONAL
TRADE AND INVESTMENT EFFORTS
THROUGH.
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA AND FOR
ALL INDUSTRY SECTORS.
THE TEAM PROVIDES ASSISTANCE TO
CALIFORNIA BASED BUSINESSES THAT
ARE INTERESTED IN EXPANDING
THEIR EXPORTS OF PRODUCTS AND
SERVICES OVERSEAS. AND ASSISTANT
ATTRACTING FOREIGN DIRECT
INVESTMENT INTO CALIFORNIA.
TO HELP INCREASE TWO WAY. TRADE
ACCORDINGLY GOBIZ HOSTS LEADS OR
PARTICIPATES AND A WIDE RANGE OF
TRADE MISSIONS BUSINESS TO
BUSINESS MATCHMAKING EVENTS
WEBINARS WORKSHOPS AND MARKET
BRIEFINGS.
THE PURPOSE OF THESE ACTIVITIES
IS TO HIGHLIGHT THE AVAILABLE
INTERNATIONAL BUSINESS
OPPORTUNITIES THE VARIOUS TYPES
OF ASSISTANCE. AVAILABLE AT THE
STATE AND THE IMPORTANCE OF
INTERNATIONAL TRADE AND
INVESTMENT TO CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMIC GROWTH.
CALIFORNIA'S HOME TO THREE POINT
SEVEN MILLION SMALL BUSINESSES.
SO THE SPECIFICALLY WE FOCUS ON
SPECIFICALLY TAILORING FOR THE
NEEDS OF OURS TWO THE NEEDS OF
OUR SMALL BUSINESSES AS THEY
INCREASE THEIR CAPACITY TO
EXPLORE. WE ADMINISTER A FEDERAL
GRANT PROGRAM WITH OUR
COLLEAGUES AT THE CALVARY
DEPARTMENT FOOD AND TAG IN THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE CENTER FOR.
INTERNATIONAL TRADE AND
DEVELOPMENT.
WE WORK IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
ENTITIES SUCH AS FOREIGN
GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS BASED ON
THE STATE.
THE U. S..
DEPARTMENT OF COMMERCE'S
INTERNATIONAL TRADE
ADMINISTRATION OFFICES IN
CALIFORNIA AND WASHINGTON DC AND
THE ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
ORGANIZATIONS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE'S.
I NOW I WOULD LIKE TO TURN IT
OVER TO OUR WE WHO SERVES AS OUR
DEPUTY.
JUST ONE POINT THAT I WANTED TO
MAKE IS PRIOR TO JOINING GOBIZ
ALWAYS SERVED AS THE
INTERNATIONAL TRADE SPECIALIST
AND CIVIL SERVANT IN THE OFFICE
OF SOUTH ASIA AT THE US.
DEPARTMENT OF COMMERCE IN
WASHINGTON.
WELCOME WATER HAPPY TO HAVE YOU
HERE THANK YOU VERY MUCH BUT IS
A SONG.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH UNDER AND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR LATE LEADERSHIP
BY CHAIR QUIRK SILVA AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE GOOD MORNING.
INTO IN TWENTY THIRTEEN JUST TO
GIVE SOME HISTORICAL CONTEXT.
GOVERNOR BROWN AND HIS
COUNTERPART AT THE CHINESE
MINISTRY OF COMMERCE OR MAAF
COM.
SIGNED A TRADE AND INVESTMENT
MEMORANDUM OF UNDERSTANDING OUR
AMMO YOU.
THIS DOCUMENT SERVES AS OUR
PRIMARY GUIDE FOR LAUNCHING
BILATERAL TRADE AND INVESTMENT
INITIATIVES BETWEEN OUR
RESPECTIVE GOVERNMENTS.
IT LINKS CALIFORNIA AND THE
CHINESE PROVINCES OF JUNK SU.
INNER MONGOLIA SHANHAI SEAN DOME
GUANGDONG JOHN CHIANG AND WHO
WAY IN A JOINT PLEDGE TO ADVANCE
TRADE COOPERATION. IN THE
CRITICAL INDUSTRY AREAS OF
INFRASTRUCTURE.
PHARMACEUTICALS INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY.
AGRICULTURE MANUFACTURING
TOURISM CLEAN ENERGY AND
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION.
FURTHERMORE IT'S REGULARLY TO
SHARE
INFORMATION ON TRADE.
INVESTMENT PROGRAMS AND EXHIBITS
DISCUSS BARRIERS TO TRADE AND
PROMOTE KEY PROJECTS.
WITH AN AGENDA CONSISTENT WITH
THESE ISSUES IN THE PRIVATE
PRIORITIES LAID FORTH IN THIS
AGREEMENT. GOVERNOR BROWN
RETURNED TO CHINA IN JUNE OF
TWENTY SEVENTEEN. DID VANCE THE
CALIFORNIA CHINA FRIENDSHIP AND
CLIMATE PARTNERSHIP.
PRIOR TO GOVERNOR BROWN STRIP
CHINA ANNOUNCED ITS INTENTION TO
INVEST THREE HUNDRED AND SIXTY
SIX BILLION U. S. DOLLARS.
IN RENEWABLE ENERGY BY THE YEAR
TWENTY TWENTY.
DURING HIS TRIP AS A DEPUTY
CONSUL GENERAL RENT ALLUDED TO
GOVERNOR BROWN MET WITH
PRESIDENT SHE'S XIN PAIN AND
OTHER CHINESE LEADERS.
TO ESTABLISH THE CALIFORNIA
CHINA CLEAN TECHNOLOGY
PARTNERSHIP TO ALLOW ALIGN OUR
RESPECTIVE EFFORTS.
IN CLEAN TECHNOLOGY INNOVATION
FOCUSED ON RESEARCH AND
DEVELOPMENT OF BATTERIES IN ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES OR WHAT WE
CALL ZEV.
CLEAN TECHNOLOGY FUNDS AND OTHER
CLEAN ENERGY RELATED POLICIES.
THESE COMMITMENTS PROVIDE A
TREMENDOUS OPPORTUNITY FOR
FURTHERING CALIFORNIA CHINA
BILATERAL COOPERATION TO PROMOTE
CLEAN TECHNOLOGY INNOVATION. AND
OPPORTUNITIES.
THROUGHOUT TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE
INTERNATIONAL AFFAIRS UNIT
CARRICO BIZ LED OR PARTICIPATED
IN A RANGE OF HIGH PROFILE.
BILATERAL TRADE AND INVESTMENT
EVENTS EITHER WITH OR ON BEHALF
OF CHINESE STAKEHOLDERS TO
COMPLEMENT GOVERNOR BROWN
SUCCESSFUL TRIP TO CHINA LAST
SUMMER.
IN MAY WE HELP CONVENE A TRADE
DELEGATION OF OF WHAT
APPROXIMATELY ONE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY CHINESE BUSINESS
EXECUTIVES. IN LOS ANGELES FOR
THE CALIFORNIA CHINA BUSINESS
SUMMIT.
THE DELEGATION COMPOSED OF
GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS AND SENIOR
BUSINESS SIX EXECUTIVES. FROM
THE AREAS OF AGRICULTURE CLEAN
TECHNOLOGY E. COMMERCE AND
INFRASTRUCTURE WAS THE LARGEST
OF ITS KIND ORGANIZED BY THE
AMMO YOU SIGNATORIES UNTIL THAT
DATE.
WITH THE HELP OF OUR STAFF THE
DELEGATION MEMBERS CONNECTED
WITH ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
ORGANIZATIONS AND OTHER BUSINESS
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THROUGHOUT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND
FROM DIFFERENT INDUSTRIES TO
EXPLORE OPPORTUNITIES FOR LOCAL
INVESTMENT.
IN JUNE IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
US EMBASSY IN BEIJING.
THE US DEPARTMENT OF COMMERCE
AND VISIT CALIFORNIA.
OUR UNIT HOSTED THE FIRST EVER
SELECT CALIFORNIA INVESTMENT
SUMMIT IN SACRAMENTO AND LOS
ANGELES.
AGAIN BE OBJECTIVE WAS TO
CONNECT CHINESE INVESTORS WITH
CALIFORNIA ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
ORGANIZATIONS.
AND BUSINESS LEADERS SEEKING TO
ATTRACT INWARD INVESTMENT. VIS A
VIS PROJECTS IN THEIR REGIONS.
THE TWENTY TWO CHINESE INVESTORS
IN THE DELEGATION.
WORKING IN THE CLEAN TECHNOLOGY
WATER AND ZERO EMISSIONS VEHICLE
SECTORS. LEARN SOMETHING THAT
ALL. LEARN SOMETHING THAT ALL OF
US ALREADY KNOW THAT CALIFORNIA
HAS SO MANY RIGHT INVESTMENT
OPPORTUNITIES TO OFFER.
THE FOURTH ANNUAL JONG SU
CALIFORNIA JOINT ECONOMIC
COMMITTEE MEETING. TOOK PLACE
LAST JULY IN SACRAMENTO AND LOS
ANGELES AS WELL.
THE FOCUS WAS TO DISCUSS
DEEPENING TRADE AND INVESTMENT
COOPERATION IN THE FOLLOWING
INDUSTRY SECTORS.
CLEAN ENERGY AGRICULTURE TOURISM
EDUCATION AND CULTURE.
AND WE ARE NOT SLOWING DOWN IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
IMITATE THE ANNUAL CALIFORNIA
CHINA BUSINESS SUMMIT WILL TAKE
PLACE IN THE LOS ANGELES AREA.
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE MILKEN
INSTITUTE. THIS YEAR SUMMIT IS
DESIGNED FOR MORE TAILORED
MATCHMAKING OPPORTUNITIES
BETWEEN CALIFORNIA AND CHINESE.
BUSINESSES ACROSS A. WIDE RANGE
OF TARGETED INDUSTRIAL SECTORS
TO PROMOTE CROSS BORDER
INVESTMENT AND BUSINESS
COLLABORATION.
WE ARE FOCUSING ON THE CLEAN
TECHNOLOGY ECOMMERCE
ADVANCED MANUFACTURING AND
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE OR A AYE
SECTORS.
BUT HAVE RETAINED THE OPTION TO
ADD MORE SO SECTORS AS THE
PLANNING PROCESS UNFOLDS.
WE'RE WORKING TOWARDS RECRUITING
SEVERAL HUNDRED CHINESE BUSINESS
DELEGATES SIGNIFICANTLY MORE
THAN LAST YEAR INTERESTED IN
MEETING WITH THE CALIFORNIA
PRIVATE SECTOR.
IN JUNE PLANNED IN CONJUNCTION
WITH THE SELECT USA INVESTMENT
SUMMIT IN THE WASHINGTON DC
AREA.
WE WILL CONVENE THE SECOND
ANNUAL SELECT. INVESTMENT
SUMMIT.
SIMILAR TO TWENTY SEVENTEEN WE
PLAN TO OFFER TARGETED
OPPORTUNITIES.
CHAU FOR CHINESE INVESTORS TO
CONNECT WITH CALIFORNIA ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT ORGANIZATIONS AND
BUSINESS LEADERS SEEKING TO
ATTRACT INVESTMENT PROJECTS TO
THEIR RESPECTIVE REGIONS.
WE BELIEVE THE SIZE OF THE
CHINESE DELEGATION WILL BE
LARGER THAN LAST YEAR'S SUMMIT.
AND IT'S ROUGH MEMBERS WILL
REPRESENT A BROADER ARRAY OF
INDUSTRY SECTORS.
I ECHOING DEPUTY CONSUL GENERAL
RAN THAT.
.
CHINESE PRESIDENT XI XIN PING
RECENTLY ANNOUNCED THE FIRST
EVER CHINESE INTERNATIONAL
IMPORT EXPO OR SEE AYE AYE E.
WHICH WILL TAKE PLACE IN
SHANGHAI THIS NOVEMBER.
THE GOAL IS TO ATTRACT FOREIGN
EXPORTERS OF HIGHLY SOUGHT
PRODUCTS AND SERVICES TO SELL
THEM TO CHINA.
THE EXPO REPRESENTS THE CHINESE
GOVERNMENT SMOOVE TOWARDS TRADE
LIBERALIZATION. AND OPENING ITS
MASSIVE MARKET TO PRODUCTS AND
SERVICES
AROUND THE WORLD IN KEY AREAS
SUCH AS HIGH INTELLIGENT
EQUIPMENT CONSUMER ELECTRONICS
AND APPLIANCES.
APPAREL ACCESSORIES AND CONSUMER
GOODS
AUTOMOBILES
FOOD AND AGRICULTURAL PRODUCTS
MEDICAL EQUIPMENT AND ELECTRONIC
SERVICES.
FORTUNATELY OUR DIVERSE
CALIFORNIA ECONOMY IS STRONG AND
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THESE AREAS.
THEREFORE OUR ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT ORGANIZATIONS HERE
IN CALIFORNIA ARE ALREADY
JOINING FORCES.
TO SECURE EXHIBITION SPACE AND
LEAD A DELEGATION OF SELLERS TO
MEET WITH CHINESE BUYERS
REPRESENTING THESE INDUSTRIES.
WE WILL PROVIDE SIGNIFICANT
LOGISTIC SUPPORT CORRECT GOBIZ
TO ASSIST OUR ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT PARTNERS IN THIS
UNIQUE OF AT.
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR WE PLANNED
TO PARTNER WITH THE TWO CHINESE
CONSULATES LOCATED IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND CHINESE PROVINCIAL
REPRESENTATIVE STATEWIDE TO
ORGANIZE SMALLER EVENTS WITH
INDIVIDUAL CALIFORNIA ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT ORGANIZATIONS.
.
SO THEY CAN PARK BUT.
VISIT THEIR RESPECTIVE REGIONS
FOR MARKET BRIEFING SITE TO
WORSE AND BUSINESS TO BUSINESS
DESCRIBE HOW WE ARE WORKING ON
BEHALF OF OR FOR CALIFORNIA
BUSINESSES. TO EXPAND BILATERAL
TRADE AND INVESTMENT
OPPORTUNITIES WITH CHINA.
IT'S A RELATIONSHIP THAT WE ARE
VERY ENTHUSIASTIC ABOUT AT
COPIOUS THANKS AGAIN. THANK YOU
SO MUCH VERY ROBUST ACTIVITY NOT
ONLY IN THE PAST BUT COMING
FORWARD WOULD LOOK FORWARD TO
THAT. WELCOME.
THANK YOU.
SURE IS AND MEMBERS OF. THAT
COMMITTEE AND TO DISTINGUISH
CASTS GOOD MORNING. I'M VERY
HONORED TO BE HERE TO A TEA
PARTY IN THIS HEARING AND TO
TAKE THAT TO SHARE WITH YOU
SOME.
SOMETHING WE HAVE TOWN TOGETHER
WITH A GROUP IS IN THE PAST
SEVERAL YEARS.
BEING.
.
PROMOTING TRADE AND INVESTMENT
COOPERATION BETWEEN CALIFORNIA
AND CHINA.
AND IT'S JUST AS SET AB HAS
MISSIONS IN A PRO TRIED TO
THIRTEEN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
AND CHINA'S MINISTER OF COMMERCE
AND SEVEN. CHINESE PROVINCES
SENSITIVE SIGNED THE MOU IN
BEIJING TO ESTABLISH THE
CALIFORNIA OF THE CHINESE
PROVINCES AND THE CALIFORNIA
TRONG WORKING GROUP ON TRADE AND
INVESTMENT CORPORATION.
WHICH WAS FOLLOWING THE.
CONSENSUS OF PRESIDENCY AND THE
GOVERNOR PRONG.
AND TO THE GLOBUS TAKES THE
LEADERSHIP OF THE TRONG WORKING
GROUP ON THESE CALIFORNIA SITE.
AND TO HOUSE
DONNA LOTS OF CREE WORKS
IN THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS.
AND I BELIEVE THIS SETUPS TO TWO
SECRETARIES OF THE.
CALIFORNIA SIDE OF OUR WORKING
GROUP.
EACH SHE'S EACH ARE A LOS
ANGELES REGIONAL EXPORT
COUNSELING FALLS IN CALIFORNIA.
AND THE BAY AREA WEANED OFF IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND FOR THE MAKING OF OUR
WORKING GROUP ALL TO REACH TO
EDCS IN DIFFERENT COUNTIES.
AND OTHER TREAT PROMOTION ALL
THOSE ISSUES IN CALIFORNIA.
AND BY DOING THIS IT MEANS THAT
OUR.
.
COMPANIES SEND CHINESE INVESTORS
COULD EASILY FIND.
THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY IS SEEN.
THE FRENCH CALLED HISSING
CALIFORNIA WHICH
A SMALL USER FOR THEM TO FIND
INVEST INVESTMENT OPPORTUNITIES
HERE.
SO. I THINK I'LL ACCORDING TO
OPPOSITE HIS TAKES SINCE THE
YEAR OF TWENTY TWELVE.
MORE THAN FIVE HUNDRED CHINESE
COMPANIES ESTABLISHED THE YOUR
OPERATION YOU SOLVING
CALIFORNIA.
THROUGH DIRECT DIRECT INVESTMENT
SO THAT'S HIS AVERAGE ONE
HUNDRED PER YEAR. AND I BELIEVE
EVERY COUNTY OF CALIFORNIA COULD
ENJOY FROM THIS.
.
ANOTHER GREAT JOB WE HAVE DOWN
WITH GO IS IS TO.
CALL GUYS MANY PORTANTINO VENTS
JUST AS.
EVERY HAS MOTIONS WE CAUGHT ICE
THE.
CHICK CALIFORNIA CHINA BUSINESS
SUMMIT IN THE YEAR OF TWENTY
SIXTEEN AND TWENTY SEVENTEEN.
AND HE'S HERE WE HAVE FOR MORE
THAN ONE HUNDRED.
PEOPLE'S DELEGATION FROM CHINA
AND TO THE GOVERNMENT WRONG HAS
TAKEN THIS EVENT
TWO YEARS IN CONSECUTIVE SO.
THIS IS VERY SUCCESSFUL AND THIS
YEAR WE'RE GOING TO HAVE THAT
THE SEARCH.
CAN FOR THE CHINESE.
BUSINESS SUMMIT.
AND TO BE SIGNED SEARCHING
TWENTY THIRTEEN WE ALSO HAVE
SUCCESSFULLY CALL DIES THE CHINA
CALIFORNIA TRADE AND ECONOMIC
COOPERATION A SEMINAR. AND WHICH
WAS JOINED BY MORE THAN.
THREE HUNDRED BUSINESSES FROM
BOTH SIDES.
AND TO ALL CREATED OUT OF HOPE A
LOT OF OPPORTUNITIES.
AND.
ALTHOUGH THE.
HAS ME ALTOGETHER SEVEN WORKING
GROUP'S RIGHT NOW.
SAYS THE OUR WORKING WERE
PERCEIVED IT STATUS.
BUT SO THEY CALIFORNIA WILL
COMPLY OF ISSUE THE NUMBER ONE.
IN TERMS OF THE AIRFORCE AND
ACHIEVEMENTS WE HAVE MADE.
BESIDES WHAT I JUST MENTIONED.
THE HIGH POWERED CALIFORNIA'S
CLEAN TECH TREAT MISSION TO
CHINA.
IN THE YEAR OF TWENTY SIXTEEN.
THE EXCHANGES ARE HIGH SPEED
BROUGH. AND TO INFRASTRUCTURE.
A SEMINAR IN MATCHMAKING EVENTS
OF THE CROSS BORDER E. COMMERCE.
ARE ALSO VERY GOOD EXAMPLES OF
THIS ATHELSTAN TO ACHIEVEMENTS.
I BELIEVE WE CAN NEVER MAKE
HATES WITHOUT THE.
TREMENDOUS CONTRIBUTION FROM GO
BASS
SO I IN THAT I WANT TO TAKE THIS
TIME TO THANK IN PARTICULAR THE
YOUR CONTRIBUTION. AND TO
LOOKING TO THE FUTURE AT CHINA
BE OPPOSED TO THE FIRST
INTERNATIONAL IMPORT EXPO AS.
MISS SERGEI AND TO AB HAS BOTH
MENTIONED.
THIS WILL PROVIDE THESE
HISTORIC OPPORTUNITY FOR LOCAL
EXPORTERS.
WE WILL CONTINUE WORKING
TOGETHER WAS KOBUS.
AND MAKE MORE CALIFORNIA
COMPANIES
I TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO YOU
ENTER AND
EXPENSE CHINESE MARKET.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AGAIN AND.
BEFORE YOU. LEAVE LET'S SEE DO
YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS FOR OUR
PANELISTS OR. ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
BUT I THINK THAT WE DON'T HAVE
QUESTIONS BECAUSE INFORMATION
HAS BEEN SO EXTENSIVE AND A DEEP
AND AND IT JUST THE MORE WE
LEARN.
WE CAN TAKE TO OUR CONSTITUENTS
AND LET THEM KNOW HOW EXCITING
THESE PARTNERSHIPS ARE.
JEFF JUST TO.
THE W. DIRECTOR.
IF YOU.
AS YOU BEEN DOING THESE ARM.
CONVENING THE CONFERENCE IS
ENORMOUS CERTAIN MATCHMAKING
SESSIONS.
AND JUST THROUGHOUT YOUR POLLS
VOTE FULLY OF WAR WHAT WOULD YOU
SAY IT'S BEEN THE MOST
EFFECTIVE.
TOOLS TO BRINGING IN THAT
FOREIGN INVESTMENT.
IN TERMS OF THE EVENTS WE
PARTICIPATE I EITHER DEFENSE OR
ANY OF THE. YOU KNOW ANY ANY THE
PROGRAM SO YOU'RE DOING DOESN'T
HAVE TO BE SPECIFICALLY WITH
THOSE EVENTS.
I THINK.
INTER IT IS WHAT WE DO IS WHEN
WE PARTICIPATE IN THESE EVENTS
WHICH MOST OF THEM TAKE PLACE IN
CALIFORNIA BUT THERE'S ONE HIGH
PROFILE ONE THAT TAKES PLACE
EVERY YEAR IN WASHINGTON DC.
THE CALIFORNIA ECONOMY AND
THERE'S A LOT OF MYTHS OUT THERE
SOMETIMES THAT WE HAVE TO
DEBUNK.
WHICH WE SUCCESSFULLY DO WITH
OUR ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
ORGANIZATION PARTNERS IN TANDEM
TO EXPLAIN WHAT ARE THE
BENEFITS.
TO DOING BUSINESS HERE AND THEN
FROM A GOVERNMENT PERSPECTIVE
WORK GOBIZ SPECIFIC PERSPECTIVE.
TALKING ABOUT THE USE OF THE TAX
CREDITS THAT WE OFFER THE
INCENTIVE PROGRAMS ASSISTANCE
WITH GETTING THROUGH REGULATORY
PROCESS CITIES AND. REGISTRATION
AND CITING AND PERMITTING IN BUT
I CAN I CATCH THEM ALL.
THAT THAT WE OFFERED TO HELP
FOREIGN BUSINESSES SITUATE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA EPIC IS
VERY EFFECTIVE BECAUSE.
A LOT OF TIMES THEY DON'T KNOW
SPECIFICALLY HOW TO GO ABOUT IT
EVEN THOUGH IT'S A VERY
APPEALING MARKET AND ONCE WE
CAN.
PROVIDE INFORMATION THAT
TECHNICAL ADVICE IT GOES A LONG
WAY.
WHAT DO YOU? BASED ON YOUR
EXPERIENCE IN WOULDN'T COMPANIES
ACTUALLY MAKE THE DECISION TO.
LOCATE HERE ARE INVEST HERE.
WELL WHAT HAS BEEN THE FEEDBACK
IN TERMS OF THE VALUE
PROPOSITION FOR CALIFORNIA BUT
WHAT HAVE THEY TOLD YOU WHY HAVE
THEY CHOSEN US.
A LOT A LOT OF TIMES YOU KNOW
WHEN I MEET WITH FOR INVESTORS
THEY SAY THAT THE MARKET HERE IS
SO LARGE OBVIOUSLY IT'S SO
DIVERSE I THINK.
THAT'S ONE OF THE THE STRENGTHS
OF CALIFORNIA THAT WE'D LIKE TO
ILLUSTRATE IN EMPHASIZE AS YOU
GO UP AND DOWN THE STATE BETWEEN
SEAT OF SERVICES.
HIGH TECH SERVICES CLEAN ENERGY
AND CLEAN TECHNOLOGY FINANCIAL
SERVICES AND THEN THE WHOLE
AGRICULTURAL SECTOR IN THE
CENTRE PART OF THE STATE. I MEAN
I WOULD DARE SAY THAT UP AMONG
ALL OF THE FIFTY U. S. STATES
THERE IS AND WE HAVE A VERY
LARGE ECONOMY.
BUT IT'S EXTREMELY DIVERSE AND
FOR ESPECIALLY BECAUSE OF SUPPLY
CHAINS AND. THAT THERE IS A LOT
OF INTEREST IN COMING HERE
BECAUSE IF THEY WERE IF THEY
SITUATED ANOTHER STATE. THEY
DON'T HAVE ALL THOSE ADVANTAGES
BUILT INTO ONE LOCATION AND I
THINK THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
TRY TO ADVERTISE AND SELL AS
MUCH AS POSSIBLE.
IT'S ONE THING I NOTICED AND.
I GUESS I SHOULD'VE REALIZED BY
CAN NOTICED TO I I THOUGHT THE
CHART IS. IF YOU LOOK AT OUR
HEART TRADING PARTNERS YOU KNOW
MEXICO.
RANKS THE TOP BUT THE REST OF
THEM OR THE MOST THE MORE THAN
ASIAN COUNTRIES WHICH I THOUGHT
WAS VERY VERY INTERESTING. SO
THAT THAT WOULD. SERVE PRESUME
THAT JET THAT YOU KNOW OUR WEST
COAST GEOGRAPHY.
PLAYS A MAJOR FACTOR SEPARATE
TO.
BEING ON THE EAST COAST AND HAVE
A MAJOR TRADE WITH EUROPE IS
THAT.
THAT ONE OF THE MAJOR FACTOR SAY
CALIFORNIA VERSUS TEXAS OR.
ILLINOIS A OR FLORIDA OR SOME
OTHER PLACE I THINK THAT'S THAT
THAT'S BEEN GEOGRAPHY IS PART OF
THE REASON IT'S ALSO THE
ILLUSTRIOUS CHINESE AMERICAN
DIASPORA THAT YOU ALLUDED TO IN
YOUR REMARKS.
THAT HELP WITH BUSINESS
LINKAGES BETWEEN CALIFORNIA AND
CHINA THAT'S ALSO JUST BECAUSE
OF THE BENEFITS THAT OUR STATE
HAS ARE THE ADVANTAGES THAT
PRESENTS.
MUSIC BE FOREIGN INVEST IN WERE
FOREIGN INVESTMENT INTO
CALIFORNIA WAIT A MINUTE SAY
THAT AGAIN. NATIONALLY ALLOWED.
I THINK IT I THINK IT IS THE ALL
OF THE BENEFITS THAT ARE STATES
THAT ARE STATE PROVIDES.
IN TERMS OF THE THAT THE DYNAMIC
INDUSTRIES THAT ARE HERE ON THE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR FOREIGN
BUSINESSES TO PARTICIPATE. IN
THAT INWARD INVESTMENT FIRST AND
FOREMOST IS THE MAIN APPEAL AND.
FOR FOREIGN BUSINESSES
MORE SO THAN OTHER STATES
BUT MAYBE I'M WHY WE'RE
REPEATING THESE BIG REMARKS
BECAUSE SOMETIMES WE HEAR.
OUTSIDE WHEN WE GO TO A LOCAL
BUSINESS GROUPS AND THINGS JUST
HOW. DIFFICULT CALIFORNIA CAN BE
AND SO WHEN WE CARE POSITIVE
COMPLIMENTS WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
WE SAY THEM.
THANK YOU.
CAN EIGHT PROVIDE ONE MORE YES
LORD FIT.
SAID DO YOU KNOW HOW MANY.
FLY SWEETLY HAPPY LOSSES PER
WEEK TO THE MAJOR CITIES
CHINA WE HAVE NINETY TWO FLIGHTS
PER WEEK.
NINETY TWO.
SO.
THAT'S MEANS YOU CAN CHOOSE YOU
DO WE HAVE THREE FRIES PRETTY TO
BEIJING AND TO TO SHANHAI ONE
TWO ONE CHAU AND OTHER MAJOR
CITIES LIKE TONE CHING'S.
CHUNG DO LIKE SHE NINETEEN DAHLE
CHANGSHA.
SO I THINK. THIS THE CALIFORNIA
IS JUST A SO CLOSE TO CONNECTED
TO BE CHINA TO THIS MIGHT BE THE
MAJOR REASON WHY CHINESE
INVESTORS.
PREFER TO REVISING CALIFORNIA SO
ALREADY VERY COMMITTEE ALREADY
CONNECTED.
SOMEONE NUMBER TO HER AND I JUST
WANNA CHARMING TO. FILL FOR A
QUESTION.
AND I WILL SAY THAT.
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE SILICON
VALLEY AND NO NOBODY KNOW WHERE
CAN DUPLICATE THE SILICON VALLEY
THING INNOVATION. A A AT AT THE
CENTER OF THE HERBS SO SILICON
VALLEY WHERE I AM RIGHT. SEE NOW
WHERE THE EPICENTER OF THE
EARTH.
HAVE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY WE APPRECIATE IT THANK
YOU.
MADAM CHAIRMAN I JUST ON LAMAR
COMMENT I BILL IS A MENTION OF
THE BEGINNING OF MY REMARKS.
THAT I WANTED TO THANK THE
STAFF RIGHT TONY I KNOW YOU
WORKED REALLY HARD IN PUTTING
THIS TOGETHER AND WORKING WITH
US AND. ALLOWING FOR US TO BRING
SOME OF OUR PARTNERS HERE TO
TESTIFY TODAY THANK YOU TO YOU
AND YOUR TEAM.
THANK YOU MA'AM TERM STRUCTURE.
ARKANSAS PRESENTA ASSIGNMENTS
DOES EXCELLENT WORK AND HER
PARTNER.
THINKING JULIA.
THANK YOU.
OKAY WILL BRING UP OUR NEXT
PANEL.
AND AS AS PANEL COMES UP WE WILL
BUT WE ARE GOING TO BE
CONCLUDING THE FORMAL
PRESENTATIONS WITH A PANEL OF
PRIVATE SECTOR BUSINESSES AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT LEADERS
INCLUDING DARLENE. CHU WHO IS
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR CHINA
AND SAN FRANCISCO. TIM KELLY THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR IMPERIAL
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
CORPORATION.
AND PETER. SHOW.
SHALL.
WHO IS THE CHAIRMAN OF CHINA
WEEK?
RAY BAO MEN.
WHO IS THE DIRECTOR SMALL
BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT CENTER OF
AN TARA AND SANTA BARBARA
COUNTIES? AND. OUR PANELISTS
PANELISTS ARE GOING TO BE
SHARING INNOVATIVE AND HIGH
IMPACT INITIATIVES THAT THEIR
ORGANIZATIONS ARE UNDERTAKING TO
SUPPORT CALIFORNIA BUSINESSES
ACCESS TO CHINA'S MARKETS.
INCREASE CHINA'S CHINESE
INVESTMENT IN CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT THE EXPANSION OF CHINESE
ON BUSINESS AND TO CALIFORNIA.
I MISSED YOU.
THANK YOU AND GOOD MORNING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MADAM CHAIR FOR CONVENING
TODAY'S MEETING AND THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ATTAIN FOR
INVITING ME TODAY TO COME AND
SPEAK.
AGAIN.
ACTUALLY I WANTED TO SAY THANK
YOU FOR THE KUDOS FROM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TING AND ALSO FROM.
COUNCILMAN WHO'S LEFT VERY.
FOUR OF RECOGNIZING THE
ACHIEVEMENTS OF CHINA STUFF I AM
I REMEMBER IN OH FIVE WHEN. I
HAD GONE TO CHINA TOGETHER WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING AT THE TIME
WHO SUCCESS RECORD AND SAN
FRANCISCO. WALKING THROUGH TEN
ON MEN SQUARE AND WHO KNOWS THAT
YOU KNOW THREE YEARS LATER
CHINA'S HAVE WOULD BE.
FOUNDED.
LA I I THINK THAT CHINA IS A
VERY UNIQUE AND VERY SPECIAL AND
THAT FIRST OF ALL IT IS A PUBLIC
PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP. EVEN THOUGH
IT WAS STARTED BY THE.
SERVICES GOES OFFICE OF
ECONOMIC WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
AND OPERATING AS A NONPROFIT.
WE DO CURRENTLY HAVE OFFICES IN
CHINA AND WE HAVE OFFICES IN
SHANGHAI BEIJING AND SHUNS THE.
UMOJA I'M VERY PROUD THAT THE
NUMBER THE. AMOUNT OF INVESTMENT
UP BROUGHT TO SAN FRANCISCO
SINCE TWENTY THIS TACTILE T. OF
THINGS
INFRASTRUCTURE IN A REAL ESTATE
INVESTMENT TOURISM HOSPITALITY
CLEAN TECH INFINITEC. THE
HIGHLIGHTS THAT I COULD.
I'D LIKE TO MENTION IS THAT WE
DID SIGN AN MOU.
WELL RECESSES THAT CITY DECIDED
DEMO YOU ON ENERGY EFFICIENCY WE
SIGN ANOTHER MO YOU WITH THE
BANK OF CHINA.
TO FOCUS ON ARM BE DENOMINATED
TRADE.
AND IN DECEMBER OF TWENTY
THIRTEEN.
WE HAD PARTNERED WITH THAT THEN
AMBASSADOR GARY LAUCK IN BEIJING
TO CLOSE THAT INVEST IN US REAL
ESTATE SUMMIT AND WHICH RESULTED
IN TO.
I THINK.
INVEST INVESTORS COMING TO
SERVICES GOAT OF SIGNIFICANCE
ONE WAS OCEAN Y..
AS A COUNCIL REN HAD MENTIONED.
THEY HAVE REQUIRED A PROJECT
THAT WILL BE.
PROBABLY ONE OF THE LARGEST
PROJECTS THERE'S FROM CHINA AND
WE HAD
ABOUT EIGHT HUNDRED PARTICIPANTS
IN SAN FRANCISCO. A WE ALSO IS
FOUNDED A.
INITIATIVE BECAUSE CHINA SOUTH
BILLS IN TWENTY SIXTEEN AND AS A
RESULT OF THAT WE HAVE SINCE.
BROUGHT TWO DELEGATIONS TO
CHINA IN TWENTY SIXTEEN AND
TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND THAT
RESULTED IN OVER FIVE HUNDRED
LEAD SINCE THEN AND WILL BE
HOSTING ANOTHER ONE AGAIN AND
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THIS YEAR. CHINA
SURF WE ALSO CREATED A SANDBOX
MANY TO FOCUS ON TECH BUT
BASICALLY TO CONNECT TECH
COMPANIES FROM CHINA INTERESTED
IN THE ECOSYSTEM THAT IS SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA. AND CONNECT
THEM TO SAN FRANCISCO INCUBATORS
AND COURT SPACES AND WE HAVE.
IN TERMS OF.
EDUCATION MADAM CHAIR WE DO
HAVE A NUMBER YOU WITH UC
BERKELEY.
AND THAT IS TO INCREASE INBOUND.
INTEREST IN.
OUR EDUCATION SYSTEM AND
PRIMARILY IN THIS WITH THIS AMMO
YOU WE ARE EDUCATING CEOS WHO
WANT TO LEARN WHAT IS THE SECRET
SAUCE.
THAT WE HAVE HERE IN. THE BAY
AREA IN TERMS I ASK JUST ONE
QUESTION RELATED TO THAT YES NO
YES I KNOW THAT THROUGH HIGHER
ED YOU HAVE.
VERY SIGNIFICANT PARTNERS AND
STUDENTS COMING HERE THAT DO YOU
HAVE ANYTHING LIKE THAT SET UP
WITH A AND ALSO FROM A COACH'S
PERSPECTIVE WE HAVE.
HELP TO CO HOST EVENTS SUCH AS
THE TONS OF FOOD FESTIVAL.
WHICH TOOK PLACE IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN AND TWENTY SEVENTEEN AS
WELL AS THE MULTI FESTIVAL IN
THE SAME TWO YEARS.
MOVING FORWARD WHAT WE'RE GONNA
DO IS CONTINUE TO.
PARTICIPATE A SELECT FEW ESSAY
AND WILL BE JOINING GOBIZ
PROBABLY AGAIN.
THIS YEAR I WILL BE AGAIN
JOINING IN THE BIO TECH
CONFERENCE WHICH HAPPENS EVERY
YEAR THIS YEAR AGAIN THAT IS A
JUNE. AND WILL BE HOSTING A
SPINOFF.
FROM CHINA LIKE WE DID LAST
YEAR WE HAD OVER THIRTY
COMPANIES COME UNTO THIS.
SAN FRANCISCO.
OF.
AFTER THEY WENT ABOUT TAKE
CONVENTION IN SAN DIEGO AND THIS
YEAR WE EXPECT A BIGGER GROUP TO
COME TO SAN FRANCISCO.
WE WILL ALSO BE AGAIN AS I
MENTIONED EARLIER HOSTING
ANOTHER CHINA US OF BILLS
DELEGATION IN SEPTEMBER I THINK
I SPOKE TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING
AND HELP BE.
COORDINATING WITH HIS FELLOW
MEMBERS TO SEE WHETHER OF SOME
OF YOU WOULD LIKE TO JOIN US AS
WELL. O. WE WILL BE.
UNDERSTANDING THAT YOU KNOW THE
WORLD IS CHANGING AND OTHER
COMPANIES ARE GOING GLOBAL WE
WILL BE WORKING CLOSELY WITH THE
SISTER ORGANIZATIONS LATIN SFN
ES OF ASIA UNDER TO BIGGER
UMBRELLA GLOBAL SF. TO PROVIDE A
WORLDWIDE OPPORTUNITIES TO ALL
THE COMPANIES THAT COME FROM
OVERSEAS AND IN THIS PARTICULAR
CASE CHINA UP BECAUSE CHINESE
COMPANIES THEY DO AND OUR FOCUS
ON INVESTING OVERSEAS AND SAID
SERVICES BETA BETA PROJECT.
TO CONNECT THE SAN FRANCISCO
BAY AREA.
TO THE GREATER BAY OF THE PRO
RIVER DELTA
THE AREA.
I THINK THAT CONCLUDES MY GREAT
JOB UP ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I
DO WANT TO ASK REALLY QUICKLY
BEFORE WE GO IS. WE JUST TALKED
ABOUT SOME OF THE YOUNGER
STUDENTS WHAT ABOUT DOLE
IMMERSION PROGRAMS. DO YOU HAVE
ANY DATA OF HELL I KNOW THERE
ARE SOME WITH CHINESE AND
ENGLISH.
BUT I KNOW THE FEW BUT ARE THERE
MANY OR DO YOU TRACK ANY OF THAT
FOR.
I HONESTLY DO NOT PERSONALLY
TRACK BUT I DO KNOW IN SAN
FRANCISCO FOR EXAMPLE WE HAVE.
MANY.
YEAH CHINESE IMMERSION PROGRAMS
AYE EVEN AT LEAST TWO OR THREE
OF THE PUBLIC SCHOOLS NOW ARE.
IMMERSION WITH CHINA AND
CHINESE.
AND ALSO THERE ARE MORE CHARTER
SCHOOLS NOW THAT ARE PROVIDING
CHINESE IMMERSION PROGRAM SO YES
THAT IS DEFINITELY AT LEAST AN
UPTICK IN THAT TIME.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LOOKED THE SECOND I
CUTS WERE QUICK QUESTION IF
FARMS ACTION MIGHT MY TWO
DOLLARS ARE THE.
IMMERSION PROGRAM AND.
IN SAN FRANCISCO. SUCH EACH SO
ONE THING I THINK YOU DIDN'T
MENTION WAS HOW MANY OTHER
CITIES AND REGIONS HAVE ALSO
STARTED TERM.
DO THE SAME MODEL AS CHINA
STAFF COULD YOU. TALK ABOUT A
MINUTE TO ABOUT THAT. ON WHAT
ELSE IS GOING ON.
IN THE STATE THAT I KNOW
THROUGH RIGHT THE STATE'S AND I
AM I KNOW THAT WE'RE WORKING
VERY CLOSELY WITH THE CITY OF
SACRAMENTO.
ANTONIO YOUNG WHO HEADS UP THE
TRADE OFFICE AND IS BASED IN
CHALLENGING MOST OF THE TIME WE
ACTUALLY WORK VERY VERY CLOSELY.
AND AND AND.
ONCE IN AWHILE WE ACTUALLY ALSO
WORKED WITH HIM ANA BELIEVE IT
OR NOT.
AND THEN LA IS ACTUALLY VERY.
YOU KNOW THEY'RE KIND OF SELF
CONTAINED ALREADY BUT WE ARE
OPEN TO COOPERATE ACTUALLY
STATEWIDE OF LIFE WORK WAS SENT
PORTANTINO FOR EXAMPLE.
THEY DON'T HAVE AN OFFICE THERE
PER SE BUT THE THING IS THAT
WHEN THEY CALL US WE DO TRY TO
PROVIDE ASSISTANCE THERE. YES.
THANK YOU WELCOME LESTER KELLY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR. HOLDING THIS
HEARING FOR A VERY IMPORTANT
TOPIC AND I'M VERY GLAD DE HERE
TO SHARE WITH YOU SOME OF THE.
WORK KELLY WAS ACTUALLY FOUNDED
BY
CHINESE.
IT WAS IT WAS STARTED BY A
AMERICAN COMPANY.
THAT NEEDED WORKERS TO BUILD
THE CITY AND CAME TO SAN
FRANCISCO AND BROUGHT A LOT
CHINESE WORKERS AND SO THERE'S
A.
VERY LARGE A CHINESE INFLUENCE
IN MEXICALI MOSTLY FROM CANTON.
AND SO WHILE WE'RE TAUGHT A VERY
EARLY AGE IN THAT AREA. EAT WITH
CHOPSTICKS
AND THE.
CHINESE FOOD THERE IS VERY WELL
KNOWN I THINK.
MEXICALI ALONE THERE'S OVER A
FOUR HUNDRED CHINESE
RESTAURANTS.
AND SO IT WAS VERY NATURAL FOR
ME AS I START ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT TO REACH OUT TO
CHINESE COMPANIES.
AND I WANT TO TALK ABOUT THAT
VERY QUICKLY BUT OF FIRST OF
ALL.
MY A PARTICIPATION IN TWO
ORGANIZATIONS ONE I CALIFORNIA
LOOK ASSOCIATIONAL LOCAL
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT. AND TEAM
CALIFORNIA WHICH I WAS VERY
INFLUENTIAL.
IN MAKING SURE THAT WE HAD.
.
PARTICIPATION IN TRAINING
FOR.
INTERNATIONAL.
EXPORTS AND ALSO FOREIGN DIRECT
INVESTMENT AND I'M AFTER I ARE.
NOT FINISHED MY TERM AS
PRESIDENT TEAM CALIFORNIA I
BECAME A VICE PRESIDENT OF
INTERNATIONAL TRADE INVESTMENT.
AND SO MAKING SURE I CONTINUE
PARTICIPATING THAT CURRENTLY ARE
JUST ELECTED TO THE SAN DIEGO
APPEALED TO. DISTRICT EXPORT
COUNCIL.
AND SO IT'S ARE IMPORTANT THAT
WE UNDERSTAND THAT THE
PARTICIPATION OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF COMMERCE WITH THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AT OUR AYE MEETINGS
AND BY THE WAY WE WERE SELECTED
AS THE DECK OF THE YEAR FOR THE
UNITED STATES TWO YEARS AGO.
BECAUSE OF OUR INVOLVEMENT WITH
STATE GOVERNMENT LOCAL
GOVERNMENT FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
AND WE HAVE THEM REGULATE UP AT
OUR MEETINGS.
V. I. THESE DESIGNER APPAREL
COUNTY DISTRICT EXPORT COUNCIL
IS REALLY DESIGNED TO. AYE
INFLUENCE AND THE.
THE INCREASE OF EXPORTS FROM OUR
REGION
BUT TO WE HAVE ALSO HAD A LINE
ITEM ON OUR AGENDA FOR FOREIGN
DIRECT INVESTMENT. AND PART OF
OUR STRATEGY IS BRING FOREIGN
DIRECT INVESTMENT FROM COMPANIES
WANTED OPEN BUSINESSES IN THE U.
S. AND RE EXPORT THOSE PRODUCTS
AND SOMETHING THAT. THAT WE'VE
SEEN NOW WORKING.
ONE OF THINGS THAT WE ARE FOUND
TRAVELING ABROAD IN BY THE WEB
THEN THE CHINA ABOUT TWENTY OVER
TWENTY TIMES. VISIT ABOUT THIRTY
CITIES.
AND THERE'S JUST A LOT OF
UNKNOWNS ABOUT OF THE UNITED
STATES.
AND SO WE WE DEVELOPED A PROGRAM
CALLED VIRTUAL SHELTER. I WERE
SMALL ORGANIZATION WE CAN'T DO
EVERYTHING. BUT WHAT WE DO IS WE
WE REFER PEOPLE TO FEEL
CONNECTED CAN ANSWER THOSE
QUESTIONS.
AND SO A LOT OF OUR WORK AND
HEAD START OFF WITH THE EP FIVE
PROGRAM. AT A TIME WHEN THERE IS
VERY LITTLE INVESTMENT FOR FOR
NEW COMPANIES HERE IN THE UNITED
STATES.
I GOING THROUGH THE RECESSION
AND WE FOUND THAT HE BE FIVE WAS
VERY GOOD PROGRAM. IT SPECIALLY
AS THE ECONOMY IN CHINA WAS
INCREASING.
AND WE'RE VERY SUCCESSFUL
ATTRACTING OVER TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS OF INVESTMENT
INTO IMPERIAL VALLEY WHICH IS
THAT THE TIME WAS VERY WERE
RELATIVELY UNKNOWN TO CHINA.
BUT WHAT WE'VE SEEN RECENTLY IS
KIND OF SHIFT.
IN THE IMPORTANCE OF AB FIVE IN
AND OUR MARKETING STRATEGY WAS.
WE HAVE IT BE FIVE IT.
INVESTMENT WHICH COULD OFFER
VIS'S.
BUT WE ALSO FOR TRADES.
TODAY WE'RE MARKETING
SPECIFICALLY THE FOREIGN TRADE
ZONES  AND BY THE WAY WE ALSO
HAVE THE BE FIVE PROGRAM.
AND SO WE ST SEEN THAT SHIFT IN
THAT'S REALLY BASED UPON. WHAT
THE INTEREST IS BY OUR CHINESE
CLIENTS
LEASES ARE STILL VERY IMPORTANT
BUT THERE'S A DIRECTION IN
CHINA?
TO PARTICIPATE AT THE FOREIGN
TRADE ZONE LEVEL. AND THAT'S
GOING ON AND COME BACK TO THAT
LATER AND TELL YOU HOW IMPORTANT
THAT IS.
IF I WANT TO MENTION THAT.
LAST YEAR WE I'M HAD
REPRESENTING THIS COMMITTEE
TRAVIS ALLEN WHO I WANT TO.
FUZHOU WITH US AND THE
SPECIFICALLY TO TALK ABOUT THIS
ITEM.
TO TALK ABOUT THE VIRTUAL
SHELTER PROGRAM AND TO ALSO
SPECIFICALLY MARKET TO OF
FOREIGN TRADE ZONES.
AND THE A FOREIGN TRADE SOME
PILOT PROGRAM A THAT'S IN THAT
PROVINCE AYE WE'VE HAD
DELEGATIONS ATANAS MATTER FACT I
JUST CAME FROM A DINNER LAST
NIGHT WE HAVE DELEGATION IN THEM
PEARL COUNTY. RIGHT NOW.
AND.
WE AND THEY DID A TOUR OF THE
IMPERIAL COUNTY. I'D TO AND LOOK
AT SOME SITES I TO BUILD
MANUFACTURING PLANTS IN TODAY
ARE VISITING WITH THAT IN MEXICO
IN MEXICO WITH CHINESE OUR
CLIENTS ALSO.
AND THEY WILL BE A SPEND
SOMETIME THE PRO COUNTY. THOSE
DELEGATIONS ARE ARE VERY
IMPORTANT AND IT'S DELEGATION.
THAT.
GAME THEIR INTEREST BECAUSE THE
FOREIGN TRADE ZONE AND THE FREE
TRADE ZONE RELATIONSHIP SO WE
DEVELOPED WITH CHINA. AND SO WE
FEEL THAT'S A STRATEGY THAT IS
WORKING.
AND WE WANT TO CONTINUE THAT
STRATEGY WE DO NEED HELP FROM
THE STATE.
AND THIS THE HELP THAT WE NEED
FROM STATE IS REALLY STAKE
STRENGTHENING THAT LANGUAGE
THAT'S IN THE LEGISLATION
PERTAINING TO FOREIGN TRADE
ZONES.
SO IF YOU THINK ABOUT IT FOR
TRADES ON THE REGULAR BAY
REGULATED BY A FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
THERE ACTUALLY ADMINISTERED AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL.
BUT THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
ALLOWS THEM TO HAVE.
AND SO I THINK WHAT WE NEED IS
SOMETHING FROM FROM THE STATE
LEGISLATURE THAT'S DIFFERENT
STRENGTHENS OUR LANGUAGE THAT
REALLY DOES SUPPORT. VIA FOREIGN
TRADE ZONES HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
BECAUSE IN CHINA AS AN EXAMPLE
THAT THE THE FOREIGN TRADE ZONES
OF THE FREE TRADE ZONES ARE
REALLY ADMINISTERED. AND.
THERE ARE THIRTY COMES FROM THE
PROVINCIAL LEVEL SO THEY'RE
REALLY LOOKING TO THE STATE
GOVERNMENT.
SUPPORT THAT.
I SHARE THIS INFORMATION WITH.
TO GO VISIT ALSO WITH WITH THEM
TONY SIMON'S FROM THIS COMMITTEE
AND HAVE HAD VERY VERY POSITIVE
A RESPONSE FROM THEM RIGHT NOT
SOMETHING WILL BE WORKING ON
TOGETHER.
I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO TALK ABOUT
THE IMPORTANCE AS I MENTIONED
TRAVIS ALLEN. OF THE THE VICE
CHAIR THIS COMMITTEE TRAVEL TO
WORK WITH THIS LAST LAST WEEK OR
LAST YEAR TO CHINA. THE
IMPORTANCE OF HAVING PUBLIC
OFFICIALS TRAVEL TO CHINA.
I THINK I'VE DONE A VERY GOOD
JOB.
BUILDING RELATIONSHIPS WITH
CHINA BUT YOU CAN ONLY TAKE IT
SO FAR AS A PRIVATE SECTOR
MEMBER.
AND IN IN ORDER TO SHOW THE
IMPORTANCE IN THE RESPECT. OF OF
OUR STATE GOVERNMENT IT'S
IMPORTANT WE HAVE LOCAL ELECTED
OFFICIALS AND STATE ELECTED
OFFICIALS.
AND WE NEED TO FIGURE OUT WAYS
TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN BETTER.
ONE THING THAT WERE VERY
CAUTIOUS OF IS MAKING SURE THAT
WE DO NOT VIOLATE THE FAIR
POLITICAL PRACTICES.
AND MAKING SURE THAT THERE'S A
STRATEGY AND A PROCESS THAT'S
UNDERSTOOD BY ALL INVOLVED. NOT
ONLY ORGANIZATIONS LIKE MINE AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL BUT AT THE STATE
LEVEL. SO THAT THERE'S NOT
MISREPRESENTATION OR
MISUNDERSTANDING WE WILL MAKE
SURE THAT THIS OF THIS PROCESS
CONTINUES. AND THAT CONTINUES
AND IS IS GOOD FOR ALL INVOLVED.
AS I MENTIONED THE PARTICIPATION
IN AND OUT TRADE CONFERENCES.
WILL BE PARTICIPATING AGAIN
THIS YEAR WITH GOBIZ AND WASHING
DC IT'S LIKE USA. AND THAT WE'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH SELECT USA AT
EXCUSE ME WITHOUT GO BECAUSE. ON
HAVING A LOCAL EVENTS IN THE
BILL COUNTING AND SO LOCAL
EVENTS THAT WOULD BE SUPPORTED
BY THE PROVINCIAL. I'M
CONSULATES HERE IN CALIFORNIA
AND ACROSS THE NATION.
AND PROVIDING FOUND TOURS I
EXPLAIN TO THEM THE
OPPORTUNITIES IN THE BILL COUNTY
AS YOU KNOW CALIFORNIA'S VERY
LARGE STATE VERY DIVERSE STATE.
AND SO NOT ONLY IN CHINA DO THEY
NOT UNDERSTAND THAT WE HAVE
FIFTY STATES BUT ALSO WITH THEN
STATES LIKE CALIFORNIA. WHAT THE
DIVERSE OPPORTUNITIES ARE AND SO
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT? THAT WE I'M
BRING PEOPLE TO OUR REGION'S LET
THEM KNOW WHAT THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES ARE SO THEY CAN
SHARE THAT. AND IMPERIAL COUNTY
AS WERE. AND EXPORTING QUITE A
BIT OF AGRICULTURE PRODUCTS TO
ASIA WE'RE SEEING A GROWING
MARKET IN CHINA. NOT ONLY FOR
FORAGE CROPS BUT ALSO FROM OUR
BEEF PRODUCTS AND FROM OUR OUR
CITRUS CROPS.
OF ONE OF THE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
US IN THEM IN THEM CALIFORNIA IS
OUR PORTS.
AND THE COST OF TRANSPORTING
GOODS TO ASIA ESPECIALLY CHINA
IS VERY VERY LOW.
I WE DID A STUDY AND IT COST US
LESS TO EXPORT. A OUR CONTAINER
OF ALFALFA TO CHINA.
THEN IT DOES GO SHIPPING
CONTAINER TO FRANCE.
AND SO THAT SHOWS YOU THAT THAT
DISPARITY. AND THAT'S AN
OPPORTUNITY THAT DOES CREATE TO.
THE REAL GOOD OPTING FOR FOR US
IN CALIFORNIA.
AND SO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE WE
WE TO WE ON.
WORK WITH OUR PORTS AND TO TAKE
INCREASE THE EXPORT SIDE OF
REPORTS.
SOMETHING ELSE AGO THIS HAS A
I'M REALLY DONE A GOOD JOB WITH
HIS THE. TARGET OF EMPLOYMENT
AREAS WHICH ASSIST WITH THE EP
FIVE PROGRAM.
AND I KNOW THAT WHEN THAT
PROGRAM WAS.
SENT TO. GO BECAUSE THEY HEARD
IT IT CREATED A DEFICIENCY.
AND I'M SORRY ASSISTED AND
HELPING. TO DEVELOP THE LANGUAGE
FOR THAT TO HAPPEN. ANY TIME
THAT THERE IS ANY BE FIVE
INVESTMENT THAN THE HOUSE BE A
LETTER SHOWING THAT THAT THERE'S
A TARGET AND EMPLOYMENT AREA.
AND THOSE LETTERS ARE TURNED
AROUND I'M IN ABOUT A DAY OR TWO
FROM GO THERE SO THAT'S BEEN
VERY HELPFUL. IN HELPING US TO
ATTRACTED THE FIVE INVEST ROCK
COUNTY. OUR ENTIRE COUNTY
QUALIFIES NOT ONLY PRETTY B.
FIVE FOR FOR FOREIGN TRADE
ZONES.
AND SO THOSE ARE THINGS THAT
HELP EXPLAIN WHY HE LOVES YOU
FIVE YEAH. SO IF YOU FIND
INVESTMENT PROGRAM IS A A
PROGRAM THAT.
ALLOWS FOREIGN INVESTORS TO
MAKE INVESTMENTS IN TO PRY INTO
REGIONS IN THE UNITED STATES.
AND IT IN TWO WAYS ONE IS EITHER
AND AB FIVE DESIGNATED AREA OR
TARGET EMPLOYMENT AREA.
I DIDN'T THE MINIMUM REQUIREMENT
ISMILLION DOLLARS EXCEPT FOR
TWO DAYS WHICH IS FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND.
AND IT'S BEEN VERY CSUS SEX
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM FOR US AS I
MENTION.
IT ALLOWS THOSE ARE MAKING
INVESTMENT TO APPLY FOR.
A PERMANENT DONE.
LEASES AND POSSIBLY IN THE
FUTURE APPLY FOR A CITIZENSHIP
IN THE UNITED STATES SO IT'S A
PATHWAY. TO CITIZENSHIP.
AS I MENTIONED WHEN A SUCCESSFUL
PROGRAM IN HELPING US TO TARGET
INVESTMENT.
AND INTO THE IMPERIAL COUNTY BUT
I WANTED I WANT TO ADD ONE THING
TO THAT.
WE'VE BEEN VERY SUCCESSFUL WITH
THIS PROGRAM.
BUT NOW WHAT WE'RE SEEING IS
REINVESTMENT BY THOSE INVESTORS.
AND SO AFTER FIVE YEARS THE
INVESTOR CAN. AND IS EXPECTED TO
RECEIVE THEIR INVESTMENT BACK
THEY HAVE TO PUT THAT MANY A
RISK FOR FIVE YEARS. SO AFTER
THAT FIVE YEAR PERIOD WHAT WE'RE
SAYING IS MANY THOSE INVESTORS
REINVENT RECEIVING THEIR MONEY
BACK AND REINVESTING THAT
PROGRAM. AND THAT'S WHERE THIS
VIRTUAL SHELTER PROGRAM.
COMES IN PLACE WHAT WE'VE BEEN
DOING IS DOING SEMINARS. TO.
COMPANIES OR INVESTORS THAT ARE
WRITTEN OR READY TO REINVEST
THEIR MONEY AND SHOWING THAT
THERE'S LOCATIONS OF THE CAN
REINVEST.
IN THE INVEST WITH WHEN THEY
MAKE THE RICH ORIGINAL
INVESTMENT. THEY ARE ARE RELYING
ON THE EP FIVE.
.
CENTER REGIONAL CENTER TO HANDLE
A LOT OF THINGS LIKE THEIR VISAS
THE TAXES IN THOSE TYPES OF
THINGS BUT WHEN THEY REINVEST.
THEIR UNFAMILIAR WITH HOW TO SET
UP A CORPORATION HOW TO.
I WHAT THE TAX IMPLICATE
IMPLICA IMPLICATIONS COULD BE
SITE SELECTION THOSE TYPES OF
THINGS AND THAT'S WHAT WE WE CAN
HELP THEM DO THAT. SO THAT'S
BEEN A SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM THEY
WERE DOING WE MADE A COMMITMENT
TO TALLA CHINA FOUR TIMES PER
YEAR. IN ADDITION TO THAT I WE
DON'T HAVE TO GO TO CHINA TO
GIVE THE SEMINARS WERE DOING
THROUGHOUT A SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
AND THEY'RE BEING VERY
SUCCESSFUL.
.
IT FINALLY I JUST WANT TO SAY
THAT THAT TO TALK ABOUT
INTERNSHIPS AYE WE DEVELOPED A
PROGRAM FOR INTERNSHIPS WE'VE
HAD INTERNS. FROM A CHINESE
ATTENDING U. S. SCHOOLS FROM
UNIVERSES SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
IRVINE PEPPER NINE.
AND THE.
A MICHIGAN STATE AND THAT'S
BEEN VERY HELPFUL FOR US AND
BUILDING RELATIONSHIPS WITH
COMPANIES AND CHINA.
BUT ALSO WE'VE CONTINUED THOSE
RELATIONSHIPS AFTER THOSE
STUDENTS HAVE GRADUATED. AND WE
ACTUALLY HAVE A CURRENTLY HAVING
A NEW INTERN THAT IS ATTENDING
SCHOOL IN XI'AN CHINA. AND SEWER
BUILDING RELATIONSHIPS AND SHE
IN XI'AN. AND SO I THINK THAT
ONE OF THE THINGS WE FOUND IS
THAT THE IMPORTANCE OF EDUCATION
TO THE CHINESE.
I'M POPULATION AND I IT'S A
GREAT AVENUE FOR US TO SEEK
INVESTMENT. AND SO ONE OF AND
AND SO ONE OF THE THINGS WE'VE
DONE IS REALLY TRY TO BUILD ON
THAT AS A MATTER OF FACT. WE
BUILT THE UNIVERSITY OF PHOENIX
CAMPUS IN THEM PEARL COUNTY THAT
WAS FINANCED.
I'M BY INVESTORS FROM CHINA AND
THAT'S BEEN REALLY HELPFUL FOR
US TO AND. I BRING INVESTMENT
AND ALSO CONTINUE THOSE
RELATIONSHIPS.
SO I THINK YOU CAN SEE THAT
THERE'S A LOT OF ACTIVITIES
GOING ON. I'M WITH OUR
ORGANIZATION BUT I THINK YOU'RE
GONNA SEE THE COUPLE A. HOW
COMPLIMENTS OTHER ORGANIZATIONS
AND AND THE SUPPORT FROM GOBIZ
FOR US HAS BEEN VERY HELPFUL?
AND W. ONCE WE WANT TO SEE THAT
CONTINUE.
WE DO HAVE OFFICE IN.
DOLLY ON A CHINA I'LL BE
VISITING THERE IN TWO WEEKS.
AND WILL BE THE FIRST TIME I'VE
VISITED OFFICE I'VE BEEN A
DOLLAR ON THREE TIMES BUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF HAVING A. BRICK
AND MORTAR LOCATION AND CHINA IS
VERY IMPORTANT THERE SEVERAL
CITIES AND REGIONS THAT HAVE.
OFFICES THROUGHOUT CHINA AND
HELPS US CONTINUE THOSE
RELATIONSHIPS AND WE JUST OPENED
FOR TRADES ON OFFICE IN THEM
PEARL COUNTY. AND THE DELEGATION
IS VISITING THIS WEEK FROM CHINA
CAME SPECIFICALLY BECAUSE OF THE
FOREIGN TRADE ZONE OFFICE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU AND I KNOW THAT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TRAVIS ALLEN.
NOT ONLY VISITED AS YOU MENTION
THAT REALLY ENJOYED THAT AND.
ON WHICH SHE WAS HERE SO WE
COULD TALK ABOUT THAT BUT
SUMMER.
DO JUST A QUICK QUESTION FOR
MISTER CALDERON POLITICS AFTER I
HAVE TO RUN TO MY NEXT MEETING.
BUT HE GET A GIVEN YOUR
PROXIMITY MEXICO I'M SURE THAT
THAT HISTORICALLY WAS A FOCUS OF
TRADE AND COMMERCE.
HOW HARD WAS IT TO? GET THE
REGION TO THINK OUTSIDE OF THAT.
PROXIMITY IN DESTRUCTIV FOCUS
ON CHINA AND OTHER OTHER PLACES.
WELL I THINK IT'S A VERY GOOD
QUESTION AND I I THINK I AM WHEN
I STARTED COMING DEVELOPMENT IT
WAS IT WAS.
START OFF BEING.
CITY TO CITY AND IN FIGHTING
THOSE THOSE HIGH SCHOOL FOOTBALL
BATTLES IN IN SO WE HAD TO
UNIFY.
AS A.
AS A REGION IN THE SECOND OF
ALL I WE DEVELOPED A COMMITTEE
WORKING COMMITTEE WITH MEXICO IN
MEXICO ITS INTERNAL. MEXICALI
BUSINESS ALLIANCE WE NEED ON
EVERY TWO MONTHS AND THEN WE
EXPANDED THAT PROGRAM WITH THE
CALICO.
THE I. KELLY BOB BY NATIONAL
MEGA REGIONS WE WORKED WITH SAN
DIEGO AND THE FIVE
MUNICIPALITIES MBAH WE MEET ON A
QUARTERLY BASIS.
AND IT'S REALLY TO EXPAND OUR
EXPOSURE.
IN MARKETING AS A AS A MUCH
LARGER REGION.
AND SO BILL COUNTIES A VERY
SMALL COUNTY POPULATION SO
HAVING THOSE PARTNERS IS VERY
HELPFUL.
pBUSINESS WITH MEXICO AND I
THINK
BECAUSE OF OUR AGRICULTURE
EXPORTS.
IT'S BEEN HELPFUL BUT IT HAD IT
WAS DIFFICULT IT WAS VERY
DIFFICULT A BEGINNING AND I KNOW
THAT THERE WAS A A LOT OF UP. A
CHALLENGES THAT I HAD I'M
JUSTIFYING MY. MY I TRAVEL
ABROAD IN TRYING DEVELOP THIS
RELATE THESE RELATIONSHIPS UNTIL
PEOPLE CAME TO THE GROUND
BREAKING IS IN SIGHT FOR
THEMSELVES. AND SO WE STUCK WITH
IT AND I WILL I JUST WANT TO I'M
MAKE A POINT. IT'S THE IT'S THE
CONSISTENCY THAT NEEDS TO BE
SHOWN TO CONTINUE THOSE
RELATIONSHIPS BECAUSE THEY DO
NOT HAPPEN OVERNIGHT.
AND SO I'M I'VE BEEN WORKING A
SPECIFICALLY CHINA FOR OVER
TWELVE YEARS. AND I BILL SO
GREAT RELATIONSHIPS BUT I WE WE
NEED TO CAN KEEP THAT
CONSISTENCY AND SALSA
CONSISTENCY. FROM THE STATE TO
PARTICIPATE IN THEIR INVOLVEMENT
WITH THE UNDEAD THESE PROGRAMS
IN CHINA.
AND I THINK THAT'S A FABULOUS
POINT I'M SURE YOUR FIRST THREE
FOUR YEARS WERE VERY TOUGH BUT
NOW I'M.
I'M SURE YOU'RE BEARING THE
FRUITS OF ALL THAT ALL THAT WORK
I COULDN'T AGREE MORE THAT THAT
CONSISTENCY IN THAT DECK
COMMITMENT LONG TERM COMMITMENT
IS REALLY. ABSOLUTE CRITICAL.
THANK YOU. SOMEONE NUMBER.
ALRIGHT WE NEXT HAVE WELL BEFORE
I DO THAT WHY NO WE HAVE A
SPECIAL GUEST THAT WALK DAN AND
I WAS ABLE TO WORK WITH HER FOR
A FEW YEARS REPUBLICAN FORMER
REPUBLICAN LEADER CONNIE CONWAY.
THERE SHE IS.
LIKE TO WELCOME YOU AND YOUR
GUESTS THANK YOU FOR COMING.
WELCOME EVERYBODY.
ALRIGHT SO NEXT WE HAVE ON OUR
PANELISTS WE HAVE PETER.
SHALLOW WHO IS FROM A GOING TO
BE SPEAKING ABOUT CHINA WEEK I
HEARD FROM OUR DEPUTY AND I KNOW
I ATTENDED ANY OF THAT.
OF THE YEAR OF THE DOG AND
THOSE TYPE OF EVENTS ARE NOT
ONLY VERY.
EXCITING AND FUN BUT I EVEN HAD
THEM TO MY NAME AND SOME OF THE
RECOVERY LOOK FORWARD TO HAVING
YOU AS PART OF CHINA WEEK THIS
YEAR. ELKAY BEFORE SOME REMEMBER
TING GOES OUT I WANT TO. THANK
HIM FOR SPEAKING ABOUT THE ROLE
OF CHINESE AMERICANS AS A
PIVOTAL UNIQUE ASSET. IN
CALIFORNIA.
A THAT COULD REALLY FACILITATE A
VERY VERY DIFFICULT. BUT
WORTHWHILE PROCESS WITH THE
INHERENT KNOWLEDGE CULTURAL
TRANSACTIONAL CAPABILITIES AND I
THINK THIS IS ONE ASSET THAT WE
HAVE CALIFORNIA HAVE THAT NOBODY
ELSE HAS.
AND REALLY.
A IT IS TRANSFORMATIONAL SO AS A
CALIFORNIAN.
OF CHINESE DESCENT.
I ALSO.
WANTED TO ADDRESS THE COUNCIL
GENERAL. AND.
THE COMMERCIAL COUNSEL FROM LOS
ANGELES BECAUSE MY.
GRANDFATHER'S ANCESTRAL HOME OF
SUN DOME HAS BEEN TALKED ABOUT
SO WE HAVE THREE ARE.
SANDEL KNEES REPRESENTED AND I
THINK IT REALLY SPEAKS TO THIS
INHERENT UNIQUE HUMAN CONNECTION
WE HAVE. HOPE I KNOW THE TOPIC
TODAY'S ABOUT TRADE. AND
COMMERCE IN JOBS BUT I THINK
IT'S WORTHWHILE TO LOOK AT THE
BIGGER PICTURE.
MANY AGREE THAT ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT IF NOT THE MOST
IMPORTANT BILATERAL RELATIONSHIP
TODAY IS THE RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN. THE UNITED STATES AND
CHINA.
NOW THIS IS A RELATIONSHIP THAT
IS HEAVILY POLITICIZED.
AND DRAMATIC AND COMPLICATED AND
NUANCED AND I THINK WE IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE A UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITY TO REALLY OUT A WIN
WIN.
.
TO THIS CONVERSATION THAT IS
REALLY GROUNDED IN OBS IN THE
SHARED PROSPERITY INNOVATION.
AND. A CLEAN ENVIRONMENT I THINK
THOSE ARE THE BUILDING BLOCKS
FOR REALLY A BUILDING AND
STRENGTHENING THIS RELATIONSHIP
SO FOR THAT REASON MADAM.
CHAIRMAN.
NO ONE APPLAUD YOU FOR THE
LEADERSHIP IF YOU OF THIS
COMMITTEE.
AND BECAUSE I DO THINK IT'S THAT
IMPORTANT.
IT IT REALLY ADDS A HUMAN
COMPONENT.
TO THE THINGS THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT IN THE REALLY THE BIG
STAKES THAT WE FACE ARM LET ME
ADDRESS SOME OF MY ACTIVITIES
OVER CHINA WEEK.
CHINA WEEK IS A NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION THAT WAS LAUNCHED
THREE YEARS AGO.
AND IN THE PAST THREE YEARS
WE'VE BECOME.
THE LARGEST.
BIND VOLUME OF CONTENT IN A
CONCENTRATED TIME THE LARGEST
OPERATOR CHINESE THINGS
PROGRAMMING. FOR THE AMERICAN
MAINSTREAM SO THANKS TO
PARTNERSHIPS WITH MEDIA OUTLETS
LIKE THE LA TIMES THE LA
BUSINESS JOURNAL ON THE NUMBER
OF MEDIA. ORGANIZATIONS WE FOR.
WE'VE HAD THE BENEFIT OF HAVING.
A MORE THAN A MILLION DOLLARS IN
MEDIA ASSETS TO SHARE AND
COMMUNICATE AND ENGAGE THE
COMMUNITY. WITH THE THINGS THAT
NOW ONE OF OUR MY KEY PROGRAMS
ARE PARTNERS ARE EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTIONS.
OF ACADEMIC ORGANIZATIONS SOME
OF THE LARGEST US.
MUSEUMS IN IN CALIFORNIA.
THE ONE OF ARE START PROGRAMS
THE CALIFORNIA CHINA SUMMIT
WHICH WE.
ARE ARE THE PRIMARY.
COMMUNITY BASED OPERATOR IN
CONCERT WITH A THE FOLKS AGO
BIZ.
AND THE CHINESE MINISTRY OF
COMMERCE AND ALL OF OUR
COLLEAGUES THAT YOU'VE HEARD
FROM.
SO WE'RE. ENTERING OUR THIRTY
YEAR.
AND. FIRST YEAR WE'VE HAD ABOUT
FOUR HUNDRED ATTENDEES.
IT'S PAST JUNE TWENTY SEVENTEEN.
.
CLOSE TO OVER FIVE HUNDRED AND
WERE ABOUT TO SEE WERE JUST
ABOUT TO BIRTH THE NEXT.
CALIFORNIA CHINA SUMMIT AND I
KNOW WE ALREADY HAVE SOME OF THE
COLLEAGUES HERE.
DARLENE I WANT TO INVITE YOU TO
REPRESENT. A SAN FRANCISCO THIS
YEAR'S CALIFORNIA CHINA SUMMIT
BECAUSE OUR MANDATE IS TO. IS TO
BE.
STATEWIDE.
SO I THINK THESE ARE SOME OF THE
ENGAGEMENT PROGRAMS DON'T TO
MEANINGFULLY BRINGING THE
PRIVATE SECTOR OF CALIFORNIA TO
THE TABLE. AND WE CAN TALK A
LITTLE BIT MORE IF YOU'RE
CURIOUS ABOUT THE MECHANICS OF
THESE THINGS TOGETHER WE'VE
WORKED VERY CLOSELY WITH GOBIZ.
.
AND THE CHINESE CONSULATE TO
REALLY IDENTIFY THE RESPECTIVE
SWEET SPOTS AND I THINK THIS IS
A PROGRAM WORTH.
REPLICATING IN DIFFERENT PARTS
OF THE STATE.
I WANT TO TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT. A WORK IN PROGRESS
BECAUSE I THINK.
.
FD I IS ONE OF THE BIG THEMES
THAT WE'RE REALLY THINKING ABOUT
WHEN YOU TRACKED. VIS VIS
INVESTMENT ACTIVITIES OF OF
CHINA IN CALIFORNIA I WOULD SAY
A LARGE A PLURALITY OF THOSE
TRANSACTIONS HAVE ALREADY BEEN
REALLY BEEN BUYOUTS.
THEY'VE BEEN CORPORATE BUYOUTS
THEY'VE BEEN EMANATE
TRANSACTIONS.
INASMUCH AS THEY DO ENJOY NEW
CAPITAL INTO THE MARKETPLACE.
THEY'RE NOT DIRECTLY RELATED TO
JOB CREATION WHEN IT COMES TO
SMALL AND MEDIUM SIZED
BUSINESSES.
AND.
WE SEE MANY CHALLENGES IN REALLY
THE FULL ENGAGEMENT. OF THIS
RELATIONSHIP.
AND I THINK ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE'RE WE STARTED TO LOOK AT
IS HOW DO YOU MAKE VIABLE AYE WE
ASK THE QUESTION.
A.
I WAS ASKED THE QUESTION ABOUT
HOW DO WE. ENGAGE HOW DO HOW DO
WE BRING MORE PLAYERS TO THE
TABLE AND I THINK.
FIRST AND FOREMOST WE'RE
STARTING AT A AT AN AMAZING
PLACE.
I CAN TELL THE STREET ENOUGH
THE IMPORTANCE OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHINA TRADE. A DEMO YOU THAT WAS
INITIATED BY OUR OWN GOVERNOR
AND THE CHINESE PRESIDENT.
ITSELF INDICATING SOLVE BUSINESS
AND PARTICULARLY CHINESE
BUSINESS
THIS REALLY CREATES THE
CALIFORNIA CHINA RELATIONSHIP.
AT A LEVEL THAT IS UNPARALLELED
BY ANY OTHER.
REGION.
SO WOULD THIS CALIFORNIA CHINA
MOW YOU COUPLED WITH OTHERS HAVE
LAID. A VERY VERY SIGNIFICANT
GROUNDWORK WHERE AND IT'S IT'S
ACTUALLY REFRESHING TO SEE OUR
CALIFORNIA LIKE DID.
HA HA I.
ARE CALIFORNIAN GOVERNMENTAL
LEADERS AND THE CHINESE
GOVERNMENTAL LEADERS SHARING ONE
DYESS AND HAVING THIS.
OF ROBUST OF A RELATIONSHIP I
THINK THEY'VE REALLY.
DONE AN EXTRAORDINARY JOB IN
LAYING A FRIENDSHIP IN A CONTEXT
IN THE FOUNDATION SO.
AS WE LOOK TO THE FUTURE.
WANTED THE INITIATIVES THAT
I'VE NOW GONNA PUT ALL MY OTHER
HAT AS A AS AN ENTREPRENEUR. AS
A SERIAL ENTREPRENEUR IN THE
CALIFORNIA CHINA SPACE I'VE BEEN
INVOLVED IN LAUNCHING CLOSE TO
NINE BUSINESSES.
AND.
THE LATEST ENDEAVOR AND THIS IS
NOT AN ANNOUNCEMENT IS REALLY A
SHARE ITS.
WHICH IS CAN WE ENGAGE A
SUBSTANTIAL CHINESE EQUITY UNDER
THE MANAGEMENT UNDER THE JOINT
MANAGEMENT OF A CALIFORNIA
MANAGEMENT TEAM.
AND WITH CHINESE MANAGEMENT TEAM
OF PUT.
AND CAN WE REALLY A LOOK AT.
BUT THE FRAMEWORK OF THE VERY
SAME ALL USE CREATED AND INVEST
IN ACCORDANCE.
WHAT THESE THINGS
BECAUSE I KNOW THAT?
FOR TO REALLY ENGAGE THE PRIVATE
SECTOR AND TO REALLY FIND.
THE. BUSINESSES THAT ARE READY
TO GO YOU REALLY HAVE TO GO ON A
HUNT YOU REALLY HAVE TO GO ON A
VERY EXTENSIVE.
FISHING EXPEDITION YOU HAVE TO
TALK TO A LOTTA BUSINESSES AND I
THINK ONE OF THE REASONS DEALS
DON'T CLOSE. IS BECAUSE OUR
INVESTORS WILL COME. THEY'LL
STAY A WEEK AND THEN THEY LEAVE
BUT THAT'S WHERE THE. THAT'S A
GOOD WAY TO START A BUSINESS
CONVERSATION IS NOT A GOOD WAY
TO CLOSE OF BUSINESS
CONVERSATION SO.
WE ARE MIDWAY THROUGH. IN.
WE'VE.
JUST TWO MONTHS AGO HAVE
EXECUTED A DEMO YOU WOULD WANT
TO CHINA'S BIGGEST INVESTORS AND
BIGGEST COMPANIES CHINA PETROL.
IN CREATING A UP TO TEN BILLION
DOLLAR CALIFORNIA INVESTMENT
FUND.
A THAT.
WE'LL PICK PROCURE THE ENTIRE
STATE ACROSS INDUSTRIES.
AND WORK WITH ALL THE VERY
STAKEHOLDERS.
TO IDENTIFY. AND TO LEVERAGE THE
BEST RESEARCH CAPABILITIES TO
IDENTIFY THE CALIFORNIA
BUSINESSES THAT.
DESERVE THE SUPPORT.
WILL HELP THEM EXPAND THEIR
REGIONAL FOOTPRINT.
AS WELL AS HELPING LAUNCH THEM
INTO CHINA FOR INSTANCE ONE OF
OUR FIRST PARTNERS.
OR PORTFOLIO COMPANIES IS A
COMPANY CALLED NEW LIGHT
TECHNOLOGIES.
THIS IS A HOME GROWN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA COMPANY THAT FIGURED
OUT A WAY TO TAKE METHANE GAS.
AND CONVERTED INTO BIODEGRADABLE
INDUSTRIAL INDUSTRIAL GRADE
PLASTIC AT BELOW MARKET THAT AB
AMONG LOW MARKET COST.
SO YOU THINK ABOUT.
AND I CAN'T HELP BUT TO THINK
THAT THERE'S PROBABLY TWO
HUNDRED THREE HUNDRED FOUR
HUNDRED OTHER COMPANIES LIKE
THIS THAT WILL MAKE A HUGE DENT.
AND THEIR CHINA COVERAGE RIGHT
NOW ZERO.
SO.
WELL IF THE COMMUNITY BASED
PROGRAMS AND THE GOVERNMENT
FRAMEWORK AND THE VERY SYMBOL
USE I THINK YOU'RE GONNA SEE A
LOT OF PRIVATE SECTOR ACTIVITIES
AND. WE HOPE THAT IN THE YEAR IN
THE DAYS TO COME IN THE YEARS TO
COME.
WE CAN BE IT A VERY GOOD
CONSTITUENT IN BRINGING THESE
VARIOUS PARTIES TOGETHER. NOW
CAN I CAN I ASK YOU DO YOU IF
YOU DON'T MIND LETTING US KNOW
WHAT ON THE INVESTMENT FUND AS
FAR AS WHAT. I'M TYPING DOLLAR
AMOUNT THAT IS
OUR FUND IS ALEC ARE. ALLOCATION
RIGHT NOW IS FIVE TO TEN BILLION
DOLLARS FOR APPROXIMATELY FIVE
YEAR FOR A FIVE YEAR INVESTMENT
CYCLE.
IT DID YOU SAY BILLION I SAID
BILLION.
THAT I SAID THAT I SEE MILLION.
OKAY YEAH.
THANK YOU THAT'S VERY
SIGNIFICANT.
IT'S VERY SIGNIFICANT WE'VE ARE.
EXECUTED BMO YOU ALREADY AND I
LEAVE TOMORROW TO BEGIN.
THE VARIOUS APPROVAL PROCESS
WITH CHINESE REGULATORS.
AND BEGIN TO BRING ALL THE VERY
STAKEHOLDERS
TO SUPPORT AND I WOULD ADD MADAM
CHAMP CHAIRMAN.
THAT THIS IS.
SOMETHING THAT.
WE CAN.
HAVE YOU PROACTIVE LEADERSHIP
ON.
AS CHINA REALLY BEGINS TO LOOK
OUT CROSS BORDER INVESTMENTS
WITH A FINE OR I.
AND THAT THERE'S A THERE'S A
VERY VERY BIG CHALLENGE RIGHT
NOW TO MIGRATE. CHINESE ARM BE
IN CROSS BORDER INVESTMENT SO I
THINK THE. PARTICIPATION OF
VARIOUS PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
STAKEHOLDERS
TO PROPERLY SUBSTANTIATE AND
SUPPORT QUALIFIED DEALS.
SO THAT THE INTENT OF THE
PRIVATE SECTOR'S CAN BE
SUPPORTED AND AUTHENTICATED AND
I THINK THAT IS ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT.
COULD AND SHOULD HAPPEN.
MOVING FORWARD.
I WOULD JUST YOU KNOW SHARE A
FEW PRESCRIPTIVE IDEAS.
AS WE LOOK TO.
A NEW ADMINISTRATION NEXT YEAR.
AS YOU BEGIN TO PUT OF THIS
MASTER PLAN AND STRATEGY
TOGETHER I WOULD URGE YOU TO
THINK ABOUT THE.
.
IN SUPPORTING THE.
INSTITUTIONALIZATION OF THE
GREAT WORK THAT THIS
ADMINISTRATION HAS DONE TO
ENSURE CONTINUITY.
AND AS A CALIFORNIAN I I GO TO
CHINA ABOUT ONCE A MONTH.
ON AVERAGE.
EYES AND I DO THINK THAT
THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY TO GROW
ARE ON THE GROUND
INFRASTRUCTURE.
IT IT'S A LITTLE SO.
VIS A VIS ENGAGEMENT SUCH A
CREATING AN INFORMATIONAL
CLEARINGHOUSE.
SO THAT ALL THE VARIOUS
CONSTITUENTS CONSTITUENCIES CAN
PARTICIPATE IN TO MARKET.
A CALIFORNIA ON A SUSTAINED
BASIS WILL MORE THAN PAY FOR
ITSELF.
TOURISM.
CONTINUE TO WORK AND BRING ALL
OF US TOGETHER AND HOSTING IS
YOUR ABILITY TO CONVENE IS
EXTRAORDINARY TO CONTINUE TO
BRING THESE ARE. ECOSYSTEMS IN
THE VARIOUS STAKEHOLDERS
TOGETHER SO THAT WE CAN NETWORK
AND SUPPORTING EACH OTHER.
I THINK TO ENGAGE ALL OF YOUR
MEMBERS.
TO REACH OUT.
.
TO GO TO YOUR LOCAL DISTRICTS
FOR VIABLE PROJECTS AND I DO
BELIEVE THERE IS A EDUCATIONAL
PROCESS.
TO ENGAGE IN THE LIKES OF YOU
KNOW I WANT TO INVITE YOU TO
DIFFERENT PARTS OF THE STATE AND
HAVE YOU SPEAK.
AS I DO THINK.
GETTING THE WORD OUT AND SHARING
INFORMATION AND THEN.
YOU KNOW.
EVERY TIME WE HOSTED CHINESE
DELEGATION THEY ALWAYS ASK THE
SAME THING SHOW IS THE LIST OF
PROJECTS.
SHOWS THE LIST OF PROJECTS.
AND.
YEAH THERE IS A WAY TO BRING
PEACE PROJECTS TOGETHER A DATUM
AND AND TO A LIKE A DATABASE OF
VIABLE PROJECTS THAT CAN BE
SHARED ON A REGULAR BASIS I
THINK THAT WOULD BE. A GREAT
RESOURCE AND TOWARD BECAUSE I DO
THINK THE INTENTION.
TO INVESTORS THERE.
AND TO REALLY ENGAGE THE
PRIVATE SECTOR. IN.
UP BRINGING FORTH THESE PROJECTS
THEREFORE THE THE ROLE OF
LAWYERS AND INVESTMENT BANKERS
SIX ULTRA TO REALLY BRING TO
QUALIFY DEALS TO THE TABLE IN A
DISCREET MANNER THOSE OF THE
THINGS THAT.
I WOULD SAY WOULD BE
CONSTRUCTIVE SO. THANK YOU FOR
THE TIME TO SHARE. SOME OF MY
ACTIVITIES AND THOUGHTS.
I APPRECIATE YOUR PRESENTATION
IT'S A VERY PRAGMATIC AND
ACTUALLY SO DETAILED THAT WE CAN
GO BACK.
ON AFTER WE CONVENE THIS PANEL
AND REALLY HAVE SOME GO TO STEPS
AS FAR AS. LOVE FURTHER OF
ACTIVITIES THAT WE CAN PURSUE
AND LA I THINK EVERYTHING FROM
MAKING SURE OUR OTHER ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU ARE
DOING SO THEY CAN LOOK WHAT'S IN
THEIR DISTRICTS FOR AS YOU SAY
PROJECTS.
AND EVERYBODY'S INTERESTED IN
THAT KIND OF ACTIVITY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THEN WE HAVE OUR LAST TOOK GAS
THANK YOU.
MORNING MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK TODAY. MY
NAME IS RAY BOWMAN I AM THE
DIRECTOR OF THE SMALL BUSINESS
DEVELOPMENT CENTER FOR VENTURE
IN SANTA BARBARA COUNTY. AS WELL
AS THE LEAD FOR INTERNATIONAL
TRADE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE FOR
THE LOS ANGELES SBDC NETWORK.
AND SERVICE A COMMITTEE CHAIR
FOR THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT EXPORT COUNCIL.
FIRST IN ONE TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO THANK THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF BUSINESS
DEVELOPMENT OR GOBIZ.
AS WELL AS THE CALIFORNIA STATE
LEGISLATURE FOR THEIR CONTINUED
SUPPORT OF THE SBDC PROGRAM.
YOUR RESOURCES IN PARTNERSHIP
PER KEY ELEMENTS TO OUR SUCCESS
SOMEONE THANK YOU FOR THAT.
THE LOS ANGELES SBDC NETWORK
REPRESENTS THE FOURTH LARGEST
SBDC NETWORK IN THE UNITED
STATES.
IN HIS DISTINCTIVE IN THE FACT
THAT IT ALSO REPRESENTS THE
LARGEST REGION UNITED STATES IN
ECONOMIC ACTIVITIES.
RELATED TO INTERNATIONAL TRADE.
THROUGHOUT THE EIGHT SPDC
CENTERS THE LOS ANGELES NETWORK
LAST YEAR WE PROVIDED TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE.
TWO OVER A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
FIRMS OVER SEVENTY PERCENT OF
WHICH CONDUCT BUSINESS IN CHINA
IN SOME WAY SHAPE OR FORM.
AREAS OF ASSISTANCE TO THESE
BUSINESSES RANGE FROM LOGISTICS
FOREIGN DIRECT INVESTMENT FDI
REGULATIONS.
FINANCE TOURISM ANY COMMERCE.
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN WE PROVIDED
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO A
CHINESE START UP IN LOS ANGELES.
THAT LAUNCHED AN EXPORT COMPANY
OF U. S. PRODUCTS AS WELL AS
REAL ESTATE DEVELOPMENT PROJECTS
AND FOR RESIDENTIAL AND
COMMERCIAL PROPERTIES.
LIKE MOST START UP VENTURES.
THIS CLIENT NEEDED OUR
ASSISTANCE TO BETTER UNDERSTAND
THE BUSINESS CLIMATE IN LOS
ANGELES AS WELL AS TO UNDERSTAND
LOCAL AND INTERNATIONAL
IMPORTANT EXPORT REGULATIONS.
THIS CHINESE STARTUP COMPANY
WITHIN ITS FIRST YEAR WORKING
WITH THE SPDC.
GENERATE INVESTMENTS LOS ANGELES
OF OVER TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS.
LAST YEAR THE SAME FIRM EXPANDED
TO THREE OTHER PROJECTS.
TOTALING OVER THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN INVESTMENTS.
THIS INCLUDED THE B. FIVE AS
WELL AS OTHER DIRECT
INVESTMENTS.
FURTHER WE WORKED WITH THE U.
S. MANUFACTURING FIRM.
IT'S SECURED SECOND ROUND
VENTURE FUNDING AS A RESULT OF
ACCESSING STRATEGIC MARKETS
OVERSEAS INCLUDING CHINA.
THE RESULT OF OUR TECHNICAL
SUPPORT IN THIS AREA OF TRADE
COMPLIANCE.
TARIFFS LOGISTICS HELP THIS
COMPANY NOW ONLY ACHIEVED ITS
FIRST PROFITABLE YEAR. BUT ALSO
LED TO A SECOND ROUND FUNDING OF
EIGHTEEN MILLION LAST YEAR WHEN
THEY ADDITIONAL TWENTY FIVE
MILLION IN JANUARY.
THESE ARE JUST A FEW EXAMPLES OF
THE IMPORTANCE OF BOTH
INTERNATIONAL TRADE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE PROVIDED BY THE SPDC.
AND THE ROLE CHINA PLAYS IN
CALIFORNIA SMALL BUSINESS
STRATEGY.
TO SUPPORT THE EXPANSION OF
OPPORTUNITIES IN OUR STATES
SMALL BUSINESSES. AND CHINA OR
SBDC PROGRAM HAS PARTICIPATED IN
SEVERAL INITIATIVES TO FOSTER
GROWTH IN THIS AREA.
FOR EXAMPLE IN OCTOBER TWENTY
SIXTEEN WE PARTICIPATED IN A
CLEAN TECH TRADE MISSION.
SPONSORED BY THE KELLY XIN
CHAMBER IN GOBIZ.
BECAUSE OF THIS MISSION.
WE ENGAGE WITH THE NUMBER OF
CHINESE FIRMS WANTING TO SET UP
CLEAN TECH BUSINESSES WITHIN
VENTURA COUNTY.
WE ALSO ESTABLISHED IN OFFICE
SPACE IN THAT CALIFORNIA STATE
TRADE OFFICE IN SHANGHAI.
TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
TO CHINESE FIRMS WHO WANT TO
START BUSINESSES IN THE LOS
ANGELES REGION.
THIS OFFICE IS STAFFED BY ONE
OF OUR SPDC ADVISORS ON AN AS
NEEDED BASIS.
TO PROVIDE BI LINGUAL TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO THOSE COMPANIES
THAT WANT TO START OUT.
E. COMMERCE IS ANOTHER
ESSENTIAL AREA OF FOCUS WITHIN
OUR INTERNATIONAL SPDC
INITIATIVE.
WE'VE ASSEMBLED A TEAM OF
EXPERTS IN THE AREA OF E.
COMMERCE BE TO BEING IN BBC.
FOR EXAMPLE WE'VE.
PARTNERED WITH GT GLOBAL WHO
REPRESENTS ONE THE LARGEST SPEED
TO SEE.
E. COMMERCE PLATFORMS IN CHINA.
THIS PLATFORM IN SIMILAR.
ONES NORMALLY COST TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS TO ACCESS
THE CHINA MARKET. WHICH IS OVER
DOUBLE THE SIZE OF THE U. S.
ONLINE MARKET WITH OVER FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION BUYERS.
THROUGH THIS PARTNERSHIP WITH GT
GLOBAL WEAKENED OFFERED GT
GLOBAL PLATFORM AND FULL SUPPORT
IN CREATING AN ONLINE
MARKETPLACE FOR LESS THAN THREE
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
IN FACT WE ALSO.
PART DURING WITH THE STATE STEP
PROGRAM WE'VE ALREADY.
THEY'VE ALREADY GRANTED SOME OF
OUR CLIENTS THOUSAND DOLLAR
GRANTS.
TO PUT TOWARDS STD MEMBERSHIP.
RECOGNIZING THE IMPORTANCE OF
ENTREPRENEURSHIP.
IN A GLOBAL WORLD WE HAVE ALSO
FOR FOCUSED OUR EFFORTS ON
FOSTERING ENTREPRENEURIAL
COLLABORATION BETWEEN CALIFORNIA
AND CHINESE FIRMS. AND THEIR
INVESTORS
SO FOR EXAMPLE. THROUGH THE SAN
GABRIEL VALLEY BUSINESS
PARTNERSHIP WE'VE ESTABLISHED AN
AMMO YOU. WITH THE REGION'S
FIRST CROSS BORDER U. S. CHINA
CO WORKING SPACE AND GLOBAL
ACCELERATOR CALLED THE I DREAM
SPACE.
THERE ARE GREEN IT WE PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO THE
RESIDENTS OF THIS THIRTY MILLION
DOLLAR PROJECT.
PROVIDING BILINGUAL START UP AND
ONGOING TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE.
TO BOTH U. S. FIRMS IN INVESTORS
INTERESTED IN PENETRATING THE
CHINA ENTREPRENEURIAL SPACE.
AS WELL AS CHINA FIRMS LOOKING
TO BASE THEIR U. S. START UPS IN
THE GREATER LOS ANGELES AREA.
FINALLY THROUGH THE PARTNERSHIP
IN SUPPORT. OF INVEST SHANGHAI
DAILY CHAMBER LYRICS.
US DEPARTMENT COMMERCE IN THE
SAME GABRIEL VALLEY THIS
PARTNERSHIP. WILL BE SUPPORTING
CALIFORNIA EXPORTERS IN CHINESE
BUYERS.
OF U. S. NATURAL PRODUCTS IN E.
COMMERCE IN THE FIRST IMPORT
EXPO IN SHANGHAI IN NOVEMBER
TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
THIS INITIATIVE WILL BE
RECRUITING BOTH CHINESE BUYERS
AND CALIFORNIA SELLERS PRIOR TO
THE SHOW. TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND SUPPORT.
CULMINATING IN THE SHOW BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY ECONOMIC OUTCOMES
FOR CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURES OF
NATURAL PRODUCTS.
SO I I LOOK FORWARD TO UPDATING
YOU ON ALL THESE INITIATIVES AND
PROJECTS AND. I ALSO WANT TO
THINK JUST THE. THE WHOLE
SUPPORT THAT WE HAVE HERE WE AT
YA I REALLY LOOK AT HER SUPPORT
PARTNERS AS A FAMILY AND.
.
YOU KNOW I ECHO ARE COLLEAGUES
AT SAY IT'S AN ONGOING PROCESS
THAT. YOU HAVE TO BE DEDICATED
TO BUILDING.
THE U. S. CHINA TRADE LANE BUT
IS SUCH AN IMPORTANT
RELATIONSHIP.
WELL I CERTAINLY CAN SEE HOW ON
NOT ONLY INVOLVED YOU ARE BUT
EVERYBODY WHO CAME HERE ON
BEHALF OF CHINA AND I THINK
YOU'RE EXACTLY RIGHT DID THAT IT
IS. THE PARTNERSHIPS AND
RELATIONSHIPS IN THOSE
RELATIONSHIPS HAVE TO FIRST BE.
NURTURED AND I WAS THINKING I
AS I I HAVE HEARD THIS
PRESENTATION AND AGAIN
REMEMBERING.
BEING AN ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
TEACHER FIRST ALMOST THIRTY
YEARS IT'S IT'S MUCH LIKE A
SCENE THAT YOU PLANT AND IT HAS
TO BE NURTURED IN AS YOU START
TO SEE THESE INVESTMENTS GROWING
GROW ON BOTH SIDES. WHETHER IT'S
AN INVESTMENTS IN CHINA OR CHINA
INVESTING HERE IN CALIFORNIA
THAT OVER THE YEARS AND REALLY
MANY MANY YEARS THIS.
BRANCHES OF GROWING IF YOU WANT
TO USE THE METAPHOR OF A TREE.
AND NOW THEY'RE NOT ONLY
GROWING BUT WE HAVE ALMOST LIKE
A IT MANY MANY TREES A FARM OF
TREES AND.
I WOULD SAY THAT.
WHETHER IT'S EDUCATIONAL
EXCHANGES BUSINESS EXCHANGES
CULTURAL EXCHANGES THERE'S UP
MANY MORE OF GROWTH THAT WE CAN
DO AS WE'VE SEEN THAT CALIFORNIA
IS A VERY DIVERSE IN PLACE THAT
CHINA WANTS TO. INVEST IN SO
THAT WE MAY HAVE A FOREST OF OF
GROWTH BUT I DO WANNA JUST
REFLECT ON A FEW OF THE THINGS
THAT.
I HAVE HEARD THAT I THINK ARE
INCREDIBLE OF THAT IN SOMETIMES
AS A TEACHER WE LEARN AND I KNOW
MYSELF SOME OF YOU TAKING NOTES
YOU CONTINUE TO LEARN.
EVEN OUR CONSULTANT BECAUSE
THIS IS HOW WE GET TO KNOW EACH
OTHER BETTER AND DO A BETTER JOB
AT ON OUR INVESTMENTS BUT. WAY
BACK FROM THE BUILDING OF THE
TRANSCONTINENTAL RAILROAD. THAT
IS IN FACT IN OUR CALIFORNIA
HISTORY BOOKS.
THAT.
YOU ARE PART OF THE FABRIC OF
CALIFORNIA WE NEED YOUR HELP
WITH THE HIGH SPEED RAIL THOUGH.
IF THEY THINK THAT WE WANT TO
GET THAT MOVING FASTER BUT ALSO
TO THE BORDER OF MEXICO LEE AND
THAT HISTORY THERE. BUT EVEN NOW
TO SEEING THAT MORE AND MORE
FAMILIES IN AMERICA ARE VALUING
THE IDEA OF KEEPING UP THE
LANGUAGE WITH THE DUAL IMMERSION
PROGRAMS. AND FOR A LONG PERIOD
WE SAW MANY OF OUR.
STUDENTS WHETHER IT BE SPANISH
CHINESE OR ANY OTHER.
LANGUAGES OF LOSING THAT
LANGUAGE UP BECAUSE THERE
WASN'T.
INNOCENCE OF.
THE VALUE OF THAT CULTURE AND WE
WOULD SEE A FAMILIES
COMMUNICATING AT A VERY LOW
LEVEL JUST WITH ONE OR TWO WORDS
BECAUSE THEY WEREN'T EVER. ABLE
SO AS A TEACHER OF ALWAYS TOLD.
MY STUDENTS AND THEIR FAMILY
CONTINUE READING YOUR STORIES
CONTINUE SPEAKING THE LANGUAGE
KEEP THAT OUR CULTURAL UP BUT
AGAIN I THINK THAT.
WHAT'S VERY IMPRESSES TO HEAR
IS INVESTMENTS ARE GROUNDED IN
JOBS IN THE ECONOMY AND THAT HOW
A THOSE JOBS ARE NOT ONLY
AVAILABLE IN CHINA FOR OUR
AMERICANS TO GO THERE. BUT THERE
ARE BEING JOBS BROUGHT HERE AND
AND STARTED HERE WITH INVESTMENT
OF CHINESE ON VESTMENTS SO
THOUGH I THINK WE HAVE. A NOT
ONLY A GREAT.
INVESTMENT NOW BUT WHAT THAT
WILL CONTINUE TO GROW I CAN TELL
YOU I. AM PERSONALLY VERY MUCH
WOULD LOVE TO GO ON ONE OF THE
DELEGATIONS I HEARD OF MANY OF
THEM TODAY BUT.
NOT ONLY MYSELF BUT OTHERS AND I
KNOW THOUGH FURTHER OUT THAT WE
KNOW ABOUT IT A. THE MORE
PLANNING THAT WE CAN DO MADAM
CHAIR WE WANT TO WELCOME YOU TO
BE PART OF THE CALIFORNIA
BUSINESS CHINA BUSINESS SUMMIT
ON MAY THIRD. HERE IN THE SOUTH
LAND SO THAT WHERE WHERE WOULD
THAT BE WOULD BE AT THE BEVERLY
HILTON HOTEL HEY WE WILL.
TRY TO GET THEREFORE NOT IN
SESSION HERE DEPENDING ON THAT
DAY OF THE THIRD I THINK I'LL
MEMBERS ARE FLYING OUT JUST
SUDDENLY AFTERNOON BUT I'M SURE
WE CAN FIND WE WILL TRY. FOR MY
DAUGHTER IS GETTING MARRIED MAY
FIFTH SO HA HA. AND YEAH YEAH
SUMMIT OR MY DAUGHTER.
BUT WE WILL TRY I DON'T THINK
SHE COMES TELL.
.
THE FOURTH.
BUT ANYHOW WE WE APPRECIATE ALL
THAT YOU YOU DID AND I THINK
THAT YOU ARE RIGHT THIS IS VERY
SIGNIFICANT AND WE NEED TO DO
THIS AND OTHER PLACES. AND OUT
WE WILL LOOK TOWARDS PERHAPS
PUTTING SOMETHING TOGETHER AND
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
INTO IN MY DISTRICT.
BUT AGAIN THANK YOU FOR YOUR A
VERY. DETAILED PRESENTATIONS I
KNOW THOSE WHO ARE WATCHING AND
CAN SEE THIS WILL KNOW THAT WE
HAVE A A VERY DISTURBING YET
DISTINGUISHED RELATIONSHIP THANK
YOU SO MUCH.
HOPE LAST THING SORRY I WANT TO
SAY.
WE DO NOT HAVE ANYBODY WHO IS
GOING TO BE SPEAKING PUBLICLY.
RIGHT NOW BUT A WE WILL BE
TAKING A A PUBLIC COMMENTS UP
UNTIL APRIL THIRTIETH IS THAT
CORRECT.
OKAY AGAIN THANK YOU SO MUCH